at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey what's going on you guys it's
Wednesday time once again for one of our
fun ass shows
I don't want to say it's not gonna be
fun but
because it's kind of like a grim topic
but I agree with Zen Maverick what you
just said there I'm so glad they caught
this [__] so ready for this
episode I was actually shocked when I
first heard about it but then I don't
know these murders aren't that old I
think I would be more surprised if they
you know figured out who the Zodiac was
you know what I mean because that was
like so much longer ago I mean these
crimes they found most of the bodies in
2010 so they did have access to like
modern day technology and stuff like
that which is a lot of the ways of uh
how they caught him it did take probably
longer than it should have
because I will note that one detail that
actually kind of honed in on him because
prior to
last year uh this dude was not on the
radar like he wasn't listed in the
suspects or anything like that
and uh the thing about it is that how he
came on the radar was a piece of
evidence that evidently had been
gathered back then but I guess it got
lost in the shuffle or somebody didn't
investigate it or something like that so
you know we'll get into that a little
bit too now I feel like we already did a
show
about the Long Island serial killer case
back in 2018
so I might like give kind of like a
summary kind of thing and all that kind
of stuff but I don't necessarily want to
go like too far into all that kind of
stuff like all the other suspects and
everything like that because we already
did a show about that but we will kind
of like
go back to it like and
at uh crucial points and things like
that because I mostly just wanted to
talk about this [__]
uh and all the stuff that's coming out
and I'm sure more stuff will come about
about him
you know in the future because they just
arrested this guy Friday like so not
even a week ago
so I've been reading like everything I
can read about this guy because as soon
as everybody found out who he was like
everybody comes crawling out of the word
work and they find out all this stuff
about him and I have to say too that
just isn't the case with BTK I feel
really [__] bad for this dude's
family like what the hell are they gonna
do now
apparently they didn't know and you know
and I believe that
so
I just I can't imagine
what it would feel like to find out
because his wife had been married to
they'd been married for like 25 years
something like that like I said very
similar to BTK
and um
she apparently didn't know
he's kind of the same kind of guy look
when you look at him he looks he doesn't
look his
mean as bzk he just looks like he could
be like a big Gumpy looking Church
Pastor for all you know what he looks
like looks like your boss
as somebody running a church so he looks
like although I will say that the um the
mug shot of him he actually looks pretty
uh creepy like pretty scary okay and the
thing about him too and a lot of people
mentioned this like when they met him
and things and if you see the um the
video of him being like taken into
custody by the cops
um he's a big dude he looks big Burly
yeah
um he's six four six five something like
that so it's like he was like a head
taller than all of the cops that were
taking him to custody and um just real
big and I was like and I saw that part
of this interview with this one guy
who um you know because the Dude Was An
Architect and he was interviewing him
about his architectural firm like on
YouTube last year or something like that
and the guy said I remember meeting him
and like shaking his hand and his hand
was like shaking marble like it was just
like he's just this big strong dude and
it's interesting because all of the
victims
at least the ones that they are at this
time attributing to him uh you know the
Long Island serial killer victims were
all very very petite young women uh they
were all in their mid-20s all were five
feet and under a hundred pounds and
under
um so the fact that he seemed like
um
I don't know that fact would almost kind
of make me think think like oh he wasn't
that big a dude so he chose smaller
women so he could
um you know so he could intimidate them
more but no he was like he was at easily
twice their size yeah which is even more
[__] it makes it a lot easier for him
yeah if he has to carry the bodies it's
a lot easier look I look at him he
doesn't look like he works out all right
um but dudes like I've said before and
it I've said before on the show some of
these guys that are over six feet are
just genetically very strong
they can yeah sit down at a [__] and
easily pressed 300 pounds and they've
never lifted before yeah which your
average guy no it's going to take a
couple years of lifting to get up into
the 300s you
put on some muscle Master some dudes
just Big Baby Huey type you know what I
mean yeah that's what he kind of like
yeah that's kind of what he what do you
look like and um like uh six five his
build
I wouldn't willingly want to [__] with
him unless I had to uh now if I was on
shred and he'd grab Jen's ass I'd be all
over and look like that damn [__]
see me do it
but uh
yeah it's always a risk when you deal
with a guy who's just genetically strong
or if he's a trade fighter you know
he's jacked he's on PDS and stuff and
he's trained you know anybody in MMA you
know it's going to be a problem your
average dude but here's the spooky thing
the average guy who's not very
physically fit can easily overpower the
average woman
so imagine
how outgunned these women were these
little five foot yeah they were small
there's no chats no chance he could kill
those women with his bare hands and he
probably did
well he could just pick them up I mean
pick him up and run with him right bash
them into stuff a blow
would be a life-threatening blow to the
face you can punch somebody so hard if
you're that size a little five foot
woman you know single blow to the jaw
right in a sweet spot and [__] her up
you know
um knocking teeth out and stuff but
chances are he probably
roughed them up to keep them subdued if
this is how it went I don't know and
then just strangled them usually that's
how they do it I think that the main uh
the Gilgo for at this moment he's only
being charged with three murders and
that's because one of the Gilgo four
Maureen Brainerd Barnes
um they don't have enough of her like
cell phone evidence and stuff like that
because we'll get into how they
triangulated his and this dude is still
alleged alleged alleged but I don't know
I read through or actually I didn't I
had someone read it to me like over
YouTube Somebody read the um all of the
like evidence yeah it was like 32 pages
and so I listened to it on my way to
work this morning and all of the stuff
they had like all the cell phone
evidence and all and there's DNA and
[__] like that too I would be shocked if
it wasn't him you know what I mean yeah
no innocent till proven guilty and
everything like that but they got enough
evidence I mean they're a lot a lot so
um and I and they might and the thing
about it is that I was watching like the
dudes like from the task force and
everything like that that came out and
said and like I said he's not he hasn't
been trial he's only been indicted and
you know arrested and charged and stuff
but it's like the dudes from the tax
task force had absolutely no
compunctions at all about coming out one
of them straight up called him a demon
walking among us and so the fact that he
is confident enough to come out and say
that and he said it on the news he said
it everywhere so I was just kind of like
well they must be like pretty confident
that they've got their man even though
the evidently according to him he's
pleading Not Guilty By the way
um well you have to well basically well
and his defense attorney said that oh he
cried and was like oh I didn't do this
and blah blah and I'm just like yeah boo
[__] who [__] who you gotta see
but from the evidence that you told me
that they had on him that's going to be
a slam dunk case unless the evidence is
bad
or Faked but they had to prove that I
mean there's just no way there there's
just too much stuff there's just too
much of a a conflation you have too much
stuff around oh [__] going on and like I
said I think that's the reason dudes
have been collected convicted on much
less yeah
so so the thing about it like so at the
moment he's being charged like it's
three counts of first degree murder
three counts of second degree murder
with three of the four like the Gilgo
four which were the four women that were
found like around the same time like in
the same area
on Gilgo Beach and uh like I said
Maureen Brainerd Barnes she he hasn't
been charged with her murder yet
although he is the prime suspect in that
so at the moment I'm pretty sure last I
heard because I've been trying to keep
up with it like I got little pings on
and everything so every few hours
they'll come out with something and
sometimes it's not anything new as far
as I know they're still going through
his house and taking [__] out
um they he also has two storage units so
they're going through those there's
gonna be [__] in there um they he also
has uh some property in South Carolina
that he co-owns with his brother his
name is Craig and uh that's I guess
where he was planning to retire to not
anymore bud but um so they're gonna
search that and last I heard this is the
most recent thing and I think this only
just came out a couple hours ago was
that he also allegedly supposedly owned
property in Las Vegas and he went out to
Vegas sometimes like on business or
whatever so so they're also
investigating that so they're going out
there because here's the thing there's
also a lot of missing escorts in the
Vegas well yeah so that's what they're
looking into because they're like you
know it's Pro it's possible probable
even that this dude has killed people
um in more than one location
and uh you know they don't know for sure
if all of the bodies found you know in
Gilgo Beach which is what like 11 it's
11 bodies right
um they don't know if all of those are
his although most of them are similar
enough that probably probably it is but
the thing about it is that I find it
hard to believe that he stopped killing
people in 2010. I think he just found a
new Dumping Ground is what I believe
happened so I think that when they start
looking more into it as they're doing
now I think that they are sadly going to
find more victims this is off Craigslist
he was finding these girls right yes
well they think the Craigslist thing
shut down in about what two thousand
well now now because here's the thing
when he got arrested on Friday they
arrested him outside his office actually
they said we didn't want to arrest him
outside his house because the dude had
um as far as last I heard they were
pulling [__] out of his house they
pulled 300 guns out of his house uh he
had 92 permits for various things but as
far as I know that was the last count it
was 300 something uh guns and they were
like we didn't want it to be like a
Siege situation or it was a collector or
hostage or something like that so um so
they're like we wanted to approach him
when he wasn't expecting it because
they've been had him under surveillance
for a long time and I don't know if they
were planning on doing it later but when
they found out that this [__]
like I said last the bodies were found
in 2010 and they thought that that was
the last of the Long Island serial
killer burners that we know of you know
what I mean I've kind of suspected
they're probably more
but when they picked him up
in his [__] pocket was one of his
burner phones we'll get into that in a
little while too
um which was one of the same burner
phones that he used to use to contact
sex workers like um on but he doesn't
use I don't think he used Craigslist
anymore because they don't do that but
he still uses like Tinder and all that
other kind of stuff and he has like all
these different
um names like fake names
um burner email accounts that he uses
just for that or just to do just to do
like um [__] up web searches of which
oh that was another thing that was super
special like I said I listened to this
what I can't remember what it was it's
32 pages and they're basically laying
out like all the evidence that they have
um you know it's like some kind of legal
document So I listened to somebody
reading all of it like through it and
they had in there a list of all of the
Google searches okay yeah that this dude
had done and it's horrifying
I mean well one of the big things okay
so
um I'm trying to think of like the exact
wording well he searched for a lot of um
you know Kitty prawn okay there was that
too and specifically 10 year old blonde
girls I'm really into that
um really into
um girls getting raped he wanted to see
porn of that he wanted to see girls with
beaten up faces like Bruce faces [__]
like that and then he was like um what
was that other thing that was like
[__] one there was one was like he
wanted to see a girl with her lips cut
off it was just I don't know it was all
[__] up but he just like he was really
into like torture and rape porn you're
right and there was like a bunch of
[__] uh like you know girl crying
with [__] in her mouth or dude you know
it was just like all [__] like that
um so yeah Special uh and also
yeah also using one of his burner
accounts he also did over 200 Google
searches for various things having to do
with the Long Island serial killer so he
was searching himself he was searching
himself and like seeing what the state
of the investigation was as recently as
I think January or February of 2023 he
was searching why haven't they caught
like something like that why haven't
they caught the Long Island serial
killer or
um you know 15 creepiest serial killers
you don't know about like he was
searching that kind of [__] how old is
he he's 59 at this time yeah
gotta say they did I don't remember who
did it um I don't know if it was like an
official like FBI police profile of this
dude like um criminal profile
but it came out in I want to say 2012
I thought they did it for the New York
Times so they might have just like hired
somebody to do it like a profile but I
was reading through it today and I'm
like man they got it bang on like that
profiling see that's not [__] they
basically said the same day said um this
is going to be a guy that is very
familiar with the Long Island area which
he is he's he was born there
um you know and he lived there all his
life there's like this is gonna be a
dude that's uh married
um and is a professional has a job uh
has an expensive car or truck
um and just like all this other kind of
stuff that that was just like completely
spot on so they really did they really
did nail it gonna say I think the only
thing that they put in the profile that
didn't end up being true well I don't
know if it's going to end up being true
or not but he's like has some kind of
job having to do where he has access to
a lot of burlap bags because that's how
he disposed of a lot of the bodies
so did he kill them on site or did he
killed him somewhere else he killed him
somewhere else and dumped fast they
don't know really where the killing
zones were as far as I know I'm not sure
because it seemed like what he would do
allegedly
was he would go and buy a burner phone
and like I said he had several burner
emails with different identities that he
would use to contact sex workers
um you know used to be on Craigslist
like I said back in the old days but
nowadays he was using Tinder so that's
why they swooped in and got him because
they're like look he might still be
doing this [__] so because he's still
contacting sex workers like recently
like just the other day you know what I
mean and he's still got the phones so
they're like we need to [__] move on
this right now before somebody else gets
killed you know what I mean yeah so so
they did that
but yeah so he would contact them and he
would always because the thing about it
is that
on I believe on three of the bodies they
found women's hair
and uh because I think three of the
bodies were uh you know bound with um
like white duct tape and then the other
one was bound with like a belt which was
kind of like another big thing but stuck
in the duct tape and stuck like around
the belt was women's hair
and they actually found out
that that hair belonged to Rex
hewerman's wife
now so everybody I mean well not
everybody they didn't like jump to oh my
God like she's in on it but it was in
his vehicle or on his clothes or
something like that because they found
out by tracking her cell phone use and
hotel records and stuff like that that
was the break they did a DNA test on the
hair no that wasn't the that wasn't the
break I'll tell you what the break was
well I mean kind of that was one of the
things
but um where uh I forgot I lost my train
of thought
um [__] I totally I totally just lost
what I was thinking of
oh well no you were talking about how
that did
he was using tape and it got her hair on
it right and uh
oh what I was gonna say was that
they tracked um his wife whose name is
Asa they tracked her cell phone and
everything like that and he and she was
um out of New York State
every single time that
um at least you know the the Gilgo for
murders that he's accused of at the
moment
um when those were perpetrated like when
the girls went missing
and when they were likely murdered so
yeah so when she went out of town like
one time she was uh went to Iceland
because she was originally from Iceland
I think she emigrated here when she was
a kid
um and one time she was in New Jersey
and then like one time I think she was
in Maryland or something like that so it
seemed like every time his wife went out
of town
he would start contacting sex workers
and then
he didn't kill all of them
because
there have been I mean allegedly some
escorts came out later and said that
they had you know had dates with him and
were talking about like how creepy and
weird he was and here the weird thing
too is that and this wasn't just other
escorts that said this but it was also
like clients and like co-workers and
stuff they said that dude would not
[__] shut up about the Gilgo Beach
killer about Long Island serial killer
it's like you like I heard this one mess
with it himself right like I heard this
one and she wasn't she wasn't an escort
or nothing like that she was like a
client like he had done some
architectural work for her firm or
whatever and she like he was at the site
like doing something like job related
and she gave him a ride home
and she said that he was like oh have
you ever heard of the Long Island serial
like he just started talking about like
out of the blue so apparently like he
would not [__] shut up about it and
like one of the other escorts said that
too that it's like he just out randomly
out of the blue started talking about
hey what do you think about that you
know what I mean so
and I'm not sure how long ago that was
but so it this seems like the kind of
dude like I said kind of like BTK where
he seems like he kind of wants to get
famous although he has pleaded not
guilty and says he didn't do it where it
does seem like sometimes when you get
like those narcissistic serial killers
there's like yeah that was me and here's
and here's more could have been some
kind of compulsion that he had a hard
time controlling so it played on his
mind a lot he thought about it and
worried about getting caught that's why
he kept Googling his names and trying to
see how far along they were the
investigation
could have been it was might have been
casting a shadow over him that's another
interpretation but it is weird that well
I mean that's not weird what's weird is
that he just would like bring it up to
random people well a lot of times when
it's on their minds you know I mean
there's
talk talk about each other people are
trying to vent
yeah I guess yeah
but that's the thing you can't stop
talking about it because they keep
[__] worrying about it yeah trying to
check with other people you think
they'll catch him that kind of [__] you
know
what do you think of that yeah yeah I
can see that that's weird that he didn't
kill he he wasn't killing them all I
guess not but he went on multiple dates
with some of them
I guess I mean that was the impression
that I got a certain one the impression
that I got was that he was a pretty
regular user of sex workers yeah
um
right I don't know how regular I'm just
I'm just saying that's the implication
that I got like from everything that
sounds like right something happened to
him in his childhood where he's looking
up Katie prawn and then he's into all
this uh he's a big guy but he wasn't
always big some happened to him in
childhood
fixated this is some kind of punishment
he's doing
he's punishing him
I'd have to know more about it yeah I
haven't seen much about now I have there
have been some people that came forward
DJ Maniac just mentioned that this this
dude got arrested like only a couple
blocks from his house or not that far
from his house but yeah so okay so the
weird thing about it too is that you
know he lived in um Massapequa Park and
the neighborhood he lived in the
neighbors are freaking out man it's just
like they they just can't believe it but
it's this is really weird this seems
like contradictory to me because
some of the people in the neighborhood
most of the people in the neighborhood
like nobody said oh my God it was like
so like that doesn't shock me at all
but mostly what they said was that him
and his family
were real reclusive like you almost
never saw them like not him or his wife
either and they had a couple kids
they're adults but he has a daughter
um who I think is 26 and she also works
in his architectural firm
so and he also has what she's going to
be out of a job
well yeah that architecture well they've
already I heard that that the website of
the architectural firm they've already
scrubbed the um the this our meet our
team page so no one could find her right
but because I'm sure she probably got
the [__] out of there and I think that
they also had a son although they keep
saying stepson so that's what the
defense attorney said so I'm assuming
that that was assa's
uh son and he I they said that he had
special needs but I don't know what that
entails and I don't know I'm assuming
the sun is older but I don't know how
old he is like the daughter is 26.
so so the house that they lived in
was Rex's mom's house or his parents
house he actually grew up in that house
and then he bought it off his mom in I
think 1994 and he's lived there ever
since then I don't know what happened to
his mom now like I don't know if she's
still alive or if she's in a home or if
she lives in the house too or I don't
really know
but um but yeah so they live there and
what everybody in the neighborhood said
was that you know not only are they
super reclusive but also the house like
it's kind of a it's not like a fancy
fancy neighborhood but it's kind of a
nicer neighborhood you know what I mean
like kind of a nice Suburban bedroom
community like they would call it and
they said his house was kind of
junkie like compared to the other ones
and some people that had actually been
in there like there was one woman that
lived in the neighborhood or whatever
and she had done like she'd been around
there like doing census stuff and she
said that she actually did get to go in
there for a second and she said that it
was like almost like a hoarder situation
like it's super super cluttered in there
so I guess that's why it's taking such a
long time for them to get everything out
of the house that they're taking out of
the house one of the things that they
said they were looking for obviously is
they're looking for
um trophies because the Gilgo for
specifically as far as I remember were
found nude and so like a lot of their
clothing and jewelry and stuff like that
is missing so it would stand to reason
that he probably kept that [__] and has
it somewhere so that's what they're
looking for they were just skeletons
when they were found
yeah okay so we don't really know how
they were killed
um like I said what I heard was
um Suffocation or like smothering okay
but I don't know if that's the case or
not because like I said I'm pretty sure
they were fairly decayed and one of the
things that I heard this other podcast
thing was that it could be
that um the reason that he put the
bodies in burlap was because it would
make the bodies Decay faster like
because he just dumped him he didn't
bury him or anything really he just kind
of put him out because if you see like
because there was a um documentary in
2020 which we watched
called Lost Girls and that was mostly
that kind of started it was mostly about
Shannon Gilbert because that was the
escort that disappeared and they didn't
find her at first but that was what
facilitated them finding the other
bodies they were looking for her and
they're like well that's not her but
it's like holy [__] who is this now and
then they found four more and then they
found six more bodies and then they
didn't actually even find Shannon
Gilbert until like more than a year
later I think it was and then and now
they're still not even sure if Shannon
Gilbert was murdered or not or if she
just died accidentally now I think
officially
they're still saying that Shannon
Gilbert died accidentally because you
know if you know that story and that
happened in 2010 where she went out to
see a client
um you know on Long Island and like near
Gilgo Beach I think it was Oak Beach was
I think the name of the neighborhood
and then there was like a 23 minute
9-1-1 call
like she called the cops and she was
like freaking out and she said like
please help me they're trying to kill me
or something like that like she like ran
from the house and then she was like
going around it was like it was like
three o'clock three or four o'clock in
the morning or something like that and
she's like going all around the
neighborhood like trying to get help
from like other people in the house and
then she disappeared and then they
couldn't find her for like a really
really long time so it was while they
were out looking for her like there was
a guy like a cop in his um you know
cadaver sniffing dog uh you know they
kept looking and looking and looking and
they couldn't find her but then in the
course of like looking for her that's
when they found the other bodies like
the Gilgo for like I said they call him
that because those were the first four
that were found and they were like
really close together I think they were
only like 500 yards away from each other
it was like or like less than a quarter
mile anyway so those were the four and
they were all in burlap they were all
bound in a similar way
you know what I mean so they know that
those four are are connected when they
started looking more they found like I
said six more sets of remains some of
which have not been identified and not
all of them were women one of them was
um an Asian man
who was wearing women's clothing now I
thought that was really interesting
because one of the searches one of the
Google searches that this [__]
did was something Asian twink something
and that kind of like pinged my radar
because I was like so I was like oh [__]
maybe he did kill that guy yeah maybe he
did kill that guy that was just that was
on his menu so um there was also I mean
they found uh I mean the bodies I go
back to like the other ones that they
found like along Ocean Beach I think it
was like go back to 2003. that's
probably all him I kind of suspected it
probably is all those bodies along the
Green River that was [__] that was
all Ridgeway
oh
it's all him
and this was and you have to think too
this is over a lot he's he's just period
of time he's dropping him off there over
a long period of time they're not being
found so that reinforces his behavior
well they're not really finding them if
they do find them they don't know who
they are yeah I don't know it's me
so you know he just keeps putting him
out there because it's convenient
yeah and one of the so one of the
victims too was a baby
a baby a baby burlap or just a baby out
there um it was just a baby I don't
think that was well no it was wrapped in
a blanket
but the baby
um I don't remember if they found the
baby first or if they found but they
found um they had a mama too I'm sure
out there the mom is out there they
found her but um she's not identified
though um they just call her peaches
yeah because she had a tattoo of like a
peach with a bite taken out of it like
on her boob so they found her and then
they did DNA analysis and they figured
out that the baby was her she was
working off Craigslist she just had the
baby with her that's yeah that's kind of
what I'm thinking so I suspect I wonder
how he killed the baby smothered it
probably probably I would imagine
yeah and maybe that's what it was maybe
she maybe he called her and like she
showed up and she's like hey I couldn't
find a sitter or something like that I
don't know and he's just like oh well
and he just did that surprised me
wouldn't surprise me if the Craigslist
girls work with babies
just bring the baby with him if it's a
baby
you can't witness anything that's true
excuse me dude might get a discount who
knows got the baby with me
dude's not gonna care yeah thank you
Zach what'd Zach say gave us a super
chat okay uh with stories like this I
always want to understand the why in
this case what happened to this dude as
a kid to make him do this stuff yeah I'd
be curious too it sounds like something
happened to him when he was a kid you
see
usually if it's very rare
that a guy that size becomes a serial
killer now there has been some what
about Kemper yes I'm saying Kemper
Keppra was pretty [__] big he goes
but his [__] went back to him as a kid
and what his mom did to him as a kid it
wasn't something that happened to him as
an adult or as a teenager it was kids
stuff some happened to him as a kid
maybe having related with to his mom or
something I don't know
all I've heard so far about
Rex heroin is that
you know some people said oh he was
bullied as a kid yeah maybe but
a lot of people were bullied that
doesn't yeah that doesn't necessarily
this is something sexual
yeah because obviously this is like this
is some [__] up [__] like some wires
are crossed in there somewhere it sounds
like a punishment thing
punishing these bad girls type of deal
yeah because even porn searches yeah
even the porn that he looks at he's
really into women tied up
um women getting raped women getting
punched in the face yeah um women crying
little girls crying yeah
um just he's real into that kind of [__]
yeah so he seems to really enjoy
watching women suffer yeah it's a
Revenge thing a woman made him suffer so
he's doing it back he's bigger now now
he can do it it's it's that that does
kind of sound like what it is right now
I'm kind of curious too if
his wife
I mean I don't think his wife knew what
was going on probably because like I
said she I think she um I can't remember
what her job was I saw somebody say
something she had some kind of like
business and she traveled a lot she
usually traveled over the Summers like
she would go back and forth to Iceland
because that's where her family was
um and she would travel a lot for
business I'm presuming because she was
always traveling in the summertime and
that was usually
when he would do his [__] so I don't
know if he actually did the [__] in the
house
or I mean that would be a big risk he
did seem to be smart enough and actually
like um I saw an interview with a guy
who had gone to high school with him and
said that he did seem in high school he
seemed very very quiet
and he also said dark so I'm guessing
Okay
um and also said he was really really
intelligent
well Jen showed me the pictures of the
four girls
Craigslist girls they just look like
white girls girl girl next door types
you wouldn't
think that they were hooking but
[__] the one we know you would never
suspect well the thing about it is a lot
of those girls too yeah because I was
watching another documentary about it
earlier I think 48 hours did a show
about it but this was like before Rex
got caught
um some of them were not I'm not gonna
say they weren't doing it willingly they
were just doing it because they couldn't
make a lot like one of the one of the
women
um she worked in a call center
also but she just like wasn't making
enough money yeah well that's usually
how it is right and that's and that's
the same thing now one of them Amber
Costello um I think that she had um a
drug problem and so she was like trying
to make extra money like for the habit
and stuff like that but it's not always
I mean sometimes these girls are just
like man I just really need to paint my
[__] electric bill or something like
that and I'm sure they're not super
happy about it but they you know you
could make I've taken precautions that
they have to take they're not getting
references and they're going with people
that just don't have although now some
people probably had a reference just
because he was he that's what you're
thinking and why he wasn't killing them
all because he needed the references
most girls would say well you got to
give me a reference and then he gives
her the name and a number of another
girl and she calls him yeah I think that
that's what that's going on he probably
can't kill them all because he needs
references because anybody who's in that
line of work I mean unless they have a
Death Wish
um usually have a few precautions that
they take you know what I mean
especially if they know somebody else
that does it it's like they kind of have
to look out for each other or they'll
have like their boyfriend or someone
like a bodyguard like drive them to
places like so if [__] goes sideways
like they have somebody to call uh call
upon
management and or bodyguards is usually
the boyfriend yeah well Shannon had that
Shannon Gilbert had that but I mean it
didn't help her in the end sadly but um
she did have somebody drive her out and
I don't know if she was murdered or not
but um you know like I said her death is
still like officially an accident I
think that's what happened he thought
she was just like having a freak out or
like a meltdown and he was just and he
then he couldn't find her and then he
was just like [__] it I can't like be
out here all night you know what I mean
and he thought she was just like have
like took some drugs and was like losing
her mind or some [__] like that and
here's the funny thing me and Jen were
just a couple days ago we're talking
about references
if I could that that one girl Ayla says
that a lot of times the references is
the reference that she accepts is the
wife
yeah yeah you can have your wife talk to
the hooker oh yeah he's okay baby you
know that's that's although she says
about one-third of them although the
thing about it was that in this
situation because apparently the wife
did not know that her husband was this
[__] serial killer which like I said
I believe it btk's family didn't know
either yeah and then getting getting the
reference from another Working Girl
wouldn't have mattered because I'm sure
he had a whole bunch of references he
wasn't killing them all so he'd go well
which is the one I had the best
relationship with and then give her that
number
yeah you know because I think he was
looking for a specific type because like
I said all the ones that they all the
ones that he killed were a very specific
type they were all very petite usually
um you know very very small something
about that and he was into that he's a
big dude he wants him to be as little as
possible so he can magnify himself over
total total power yeah big time and
watching one he wants to see him grovel
in bed
yeah yeah he really does seem like that
kind of dude because you have to take
him somewhere to where that can happen
so where do you do this
see that's what I'm wondering and that's
one thing and maybe somebody has
addressed this like I've tried you know
obviously I couldn't read everything
because there's [__] tons of [__]
coming out now there's like millions of
Articles and millions of YouTube videos
and so I couldn't go through it all in
like a couple of days
but I didn't really see anybody address
that
um where he's killing them I'm assuming
that they're you know checking his house
and stuff like that I don't think he was
dumb enough to kill the women in the
house that he shared with his family and
he can't take him to a motel right
because yeah that would be like too many
too many eyes on you I feel like you'd
have to do this in kind of a secluded
area wooded area
so now I'm kind of wondering I mean you
get them out there they took his car
into custody too Chevy Avalanche oh wait
a minute wait a minute what
usually
usually the girl is going to want you to
get a hotel room
he might have had her hotel room they'll
find out
and the hotel might have had convenient
parking
he ties her up in the room
and because she's small he can pick her
up and put her in the trunk and then
drives her out somewhere yeah maybe so
maybe that's why they had to be small
make them more portable
yeah so it wouldn't like be immediately
and I'm assuming that if he did take him
to a hotel it would have to be like some
shitty place that didn't have like
[__] security cameras yeah or yeah
exactly like a like you know little flat
motels like from the 60s yeah you can
just pull right up to the right up to
the door right up to the room right and
what you do is you you do something
that's kind of late night you arranged
something's kind of late night
on a weekday where there isn't maybe
it's dead at the motel you know what I
mean and um
you mess around with her a little bit
and then as soon as she's copper with
you you just never throw her in the
trunk
and you just drive out
like you know what I mean and just check
out the hotel
they're not gonna look and the fact that
this dude like I said nobody I don't
think anybody suspected he was a serial
killer but
um I did hear a lot of people that had
dealt with him like professionally or
that were his neighbors and [__] like
that that
um weren't big fans like I said they the
neighbors all said that he was real
reclusive you never saw him he always
seemed kind of angry
um his wife
they um they said that she would do the
grocery shopping like once or twice a
week and like she always looked super
miserable
um and they said that a lot of times she
used food stamps which seemed kind of
weird because they had money yeah I
thought yeah it seemed like his business
was fairly successful unless he was
bullshitting however they did find out
later on that he actually owed what was
it 450 000 like in back taxes like going
back to 2005 or something like that so
it could be that he was telling his
family oh yeah we got money in bloody
blah and then he was not paying taxes
and maybe blowing money on Craigslist
maybe and [__] like that but not telling
them where the money was going but I
mean obviously the wife had to know
something was up with the finances
because she was having to use food
stamps like to buy food with and didn't
look super happy about it according to
people that worked at the grocery store
that saw her all the time he must have
been kind of a sex addict
two yeah he probably was blowing a lot
of money on hookers
well I mean one of the one of the sex
workers I mean before she disappeared
like before she got murdered she like
deposited 900 yeah in her account so
it's like she was making maybe 900 a pop
yeah which that's about right for New
York right you just go on trist.link you
guys will see Tom knows all about it
you can look up any area in any region
and find and see what prices are like
thank you Jeffy art
I like that I always like it yeah
yeah Ben says Icelandic people are
always miserable
he was probably uh
probably pretty controlling that's what
I suspect I think I don't think he was
abusive where he's like beating on her
he was probably just a real [__] drag
micromanaged everything
it's probably yeah everybody at work
everybody that he worked with and like
his clients and stuff they didn't
necessarily say he was a jerk or
anything some of them did say he was
arrogant
um
but most of them said that he was real
meticulous so he's like like super
detail-oriented so he like kind of anal
retentive is I guess what they were
getting at
um which I guess is a good thing to have
if you're you know an architect and
stuff but I don't know if it's still up
there but for a while there was a
YouTube video because remember like I
said there was this guy that um he had
like a uh what was it like a real estate
or an architecture like YouTube channel
and he interviewed this dude like a year
ago before he was even on the radar and
it's just creepy like watching him
because he's so normal you know what I
mean like he seems like a dick like he
seems kind of like a like a blowhard you
know what I mean so I don't wouldn't
want to hang out with him or nothing but
it's like other than that he just comes
across as just like a regular schlubby
business dude which is crazy and it's
crazy to think that he was just had this
complete double life that he was doing
like that even his [__] family
he was a demon walking amongst us yeah
he straight up said that yeah he said it
on the [__] news and he even said it
on the um on the um what do you call it
the uh press conference yeah like he
basically said he just came right out
and said that and I was like [__] yeah I
guess they must be real sure that they
have all the evidence against this
[__] they wouldn't be or they
would say the alleged suspect has known
who he is for a long time he just had to
get all the evidence well like I said
they have what ended up happening was
that like I said you know they found the
bodies in 2010 right
that was when they were looking for
Shannon Gilbert then they found those
four bodies that they found the other
six bodies and then eventually in 2011
they found Shannon Gilbert's body like I
said they don't know if Shannon Gilbert
is one of the mer of one of the murder
victims or if she died accidentally I
don't really know I tend to think
officially it's an accident at least so
she just was on drugs and she ran away
and got lost and like you know drowned
into Marsh or whatever but I was like
two things
kind of make me question that one she
was found face up uh which is not
usually how you found a drowning victim
not you know it's possible but not
likely and two
um the Gilbert family
uh they commissioned they or they got a
um like an independent uh
what do you call it a mortician whatever
they call it to do an autopsy and uh he
in his opinion he thought that she had
been strangled because her hyoid bone
was uh broken
he definitely had the strength so yeah
so I suspect that she might be uh one of
the victims as well but like I said
they're not
they're not giving they've given out a
lot of information I will say but
they're still they're like well the
investigation is still ongoing we're
sure that there will probably won't be
more charges forthcoming I think his
first court date is like August 1st or
something but I don't know like what
exactly they're gonna do on that day
but um but yeah so at the moment it's
just three
three victims that they're focusing on
because that's what they have the most
um evidence for so I'm guessing what you
know as they find more evidence because
they're still searching all his
properties and stuff
um then it'll kind of come out and
they'll do that later
um coroner that was the word that I was
looking for thank you I can't do a point
where it's just like I was like what's
that thing in the deal and it's like I
can't [__] think of words anymore
it's like it's really sucky
but yeah so what ended up happening so
yeah so like all the bodies were found
in 2010 and remember when we did the
show in 2018
they have like a big long list of
suspects
you know John bitroth
um you know that weird doctor that uh
supposedly gave Shannon Gilbert some
drugs and said he ran a home for Wayward
girls like that Peter Hackett I think
was that dude's name
um and that was who Shannon Gilbert's
mom I think she sued him because she
thought that he had done something to
her or whatever but I think that didn't
go anywhere and actually Shannon's Mom
this is [__] up Shannon's Mom Mary she
got murdered
by her other daughter
you know like um what's her other
daughter's name Sherry Sherry something
like that and the creepy thing about it
is that the 48-hour show which I don't
remember when that came out 2016 2017
like before all that happened
um they interviewed that girl this is
like Shannon's sister and then later on
she ended up killing her mom like
stabbing her mom to death and I'm just
like the [__] man yeah it was [__]
crazy
but yeah so 2010 2011 they find all the
bodies and then you know it the case
went nowhere and it was just kind of
like it was just stalled they had no
idea who this [__] was they had
all these suspects but really
nothing you know what I mean and then I
guess in 2022 they somebody lit a fire
under their ass and they decided you
know what we're gonna figure this [__]
out so they like put together a task
force they put people on it like full
time you know what I mean because she
you know normally if you have like you
know if you're a crime like murder
investigator or whatever you usually
have like a bunch of cases going at once
and they had at least one person maybe
more than that like working on this all
full time
so they started doing that
a month or two after they formed the
task force
the task force came up they were going
through all the old evidence again and
these were all people that hadn't worked
on the original investigation because
they said they specifically wanted fresh
eyes quote unquote
so they had all these people go in there
and somebody found this old piece of
evidence from one of the Gilgo 4 cases
and there was a thing in there that a
witness had reported seeing one of the
victims get into a first generation
Chevy Avalanche with a dude that was
like real big with like dark hair
um you know they described them actually
a bunch of the witnesses described him
looking like quote unquote and ogre
which
yeah I can see it well like I said he's
a big hulking dude he had kind of that
messy hair he has you know that he does
kind of look like an ogre somebody like
earlier said that he had like a big huge
head and like really small features like
a
like a comic book villain or something
yeah it looks like something from like
Dick Tracy yeah I saw you know I saw him
only briefly he looks just kind of
Germanic looks you know I remember I
remember him being blonde not dark hair
though
no he's he has dark hair is it dark okay
yeah that's just my memory and it's just
kind of City I thought he was blonde no
okay
but uh but yeah so what's his last name
humor man okay yeah that sounds like a
dramatic name it is a yeah I'm pretty
sure that's the German last thing
but um but yeah so so they remembered
they're like oh Chevy Avalanche
and they investigated that Chevy
Avalanche
and they they found the name Rex
hewerman now Rex humerman it should be
noted had not been on anyone's radar he
wasn't any of the suspects I don't think
his name had come up prior to
2022. yeah like he was just operating
completely under the radar nobody knew
about this dude but they brought his
name up and then they started
um issuing subpoenas for like all this
information like cell phone information
all that other kind of stuff and then
they went like through all the old uh
you know crime cases and everything what
they found out
was that as I mentioned earlier
humor men had
burner phones he would go into like a
Verizon store or whatever and he would
buy like a prepaid phone if he was
planning on doing some [__] like
contacting some sections how long did he
keep these phones for see that's the
thing when they caught they had a lot of
them he did have a lot of them okay he
generally I think the implication was
that every time he was gonna do like to
use btk's terminology when he was
working on a new quote-unquote project
um he would go get a new one
but I think he used the same one
for very for other things but I think
every time he was gonna do a murder
he would get a new one but he had like a
bunch of burner email accounts too that
had fake names like he like he was um
Thomas Hawk I think was one of his names
um Andrew Roberts I think like so he had
like all these pseudonyms
and he had all of these email like free
email accounts that went along with it
so he could do [__] without
getting into trouble
so what they found out when they linked
him to all these phones because he had a
personal phone too that was um you know
through his company
and they found out that not only
was he in the same location as these
burner phones obviously because they're
his but you know they have to link all
that information but they found all the
records of him contacting these cell
phones of the victims like shortly
before they disappeared were the victims
were their cell phones burn their phones
or their regular cell phones no they
were just regular so they were giving
out their regular numbers well I I don't
know if they were like all the time but
they did I mean the way that they talked
about it they said yeah like you know
Amber Costello's cell phone or something
like that so I guess she was just using
a regular cell phone yeah rather than a
burner phone yeah because I would think
that they would professional girls would
use burner phones
so you wouldn't know what their real
phone number was right you only know
what their their business number is I
mean it could be but I mean it could be
that maybe they had them linked somehow
well because here's the weird thing is
that well and this is [__] up too
here's another thing that humor men
allegedly
um got off on and it particularly I
think this was in the case of um I think
it was Melissa barthelemy who was one of
the uh Gilgo four
after he killed her he took her cell
phone and used it to call her family and
taunt them about
killing her damn what do you say he
called the sister now at this point like
I said the the mom and the sister were
freaking out because you know she'd been
missing for a long time and they didn't
know where she was they hadn't found
well they hadn't found the body yet okay
so um
so they get a phone call from her phone
and they're all excited because they're
like oh my god there she is finally and
they pick it up and it's this [__]
dude and he says to the sister who's
like a young I think she was like a
little teenager or something like that
he says do you are you a [__] like your
sister he said something like that to
her and then he was like oh she was in a
whorehouse in Queens or some [__] like
that and then he told her in great
detail like what he did to her what was
that what what was it well he told her
about like the rape and he told her
about how he killed her and all this
other how did he kill her well I don't
know I don't know I don't have them
because they didn't give the details no
no I'm just saying that that's what yeah
so that's what the sister said so the
guy and that was another thing
that the guy did was that he
um that was some of the other Google
searches that he did he wasn't only
searching for himself he was searching
for the victim's families like pictures
of their families like how to get in
contact with them so that was another
thing that he got off on was like
calling them with the victim's cell
phones like after they were dead yeah
Albert Fish and yeah yeah and like and
taunting the families about hey yeah I
killed him and blah blah so he was doing
that kind of [__] too he's doing that
from his burner phone no he did that
from the victim from the victim's phone
that's right that's right yeah he did
that from the video Yeah and could they
they I guess they couldn't track down
where that phone was at the time that he
called huh
yeah well I mean but the thing about it
was that they didn't know yeah they
didn't know it was him until a bunch
later until later yeah now that they
know who it is they can go pull all the
cell phone records right right and see
what's going on
and that's what they did so like once
they caught him they pulled all his cell
phone records They found out all these
burner phones that he had like that were
all Linked UP they knew that they were
his like I said because one he was in
the same location as them like all the
time that they were used and two I think
he also used the burner phone at 1.2
like check his well just check his email
or check his voicemail on his regular
phone or something like that like he did
something that like linked him to it
right and there was also
um the victims phones and his phone were
like in the same location like a lot of
times so they actually said like they
listed all of these I mean like I said
it was a 32-page thing oh he's gone man
so they listed all of these things where
it's like you know at this time like
this the victim's cell phone was here
and this you know this motherfucker's
regular cell phone was here and the
burner phone was here like this phone
number so when he was caught when he was
calling the families and taunting them
on their phones they know where he was
when he made that call was he at home
was he at home calling him sometimes
sometimes he was at his office or around
his office because his office is in
Midtown Manhattan it's actually on Fifth
Avenue and 36th Street
um and that's actually where they caught
him so the thing about it was that they
pulled all these cell phone records and
they're like okay well it's very
significant that every single time that
you know like before these girls
disappeared their phone is like the same
place as this dude pretty much yeah
um and they knew that he had contacted
them because they pulled all the data
from the burner phone so they knew that
he had talked to them like a day or two
before they had disappeared and one of
the victims I think it was Amber
Costello
he um had seen her before
and he actually went to her house I
think
I'm pretty sure this was Amber Costello
and she tried to pull worksheet
successfully pulled a scam on him where
she he came to her house like they set
up a date he came to her house and she
took the money and then she had a friend
of hers pretend he was like the outraged
boyfriend and he comes in like what the
[__] is going on blah blah so he had
somebody do that and ran Rex humor man
out damn and so and then she kept the
money and then so they have
um they pulled the records and a couple
days after that Rex called her again and
set up another date oh do I get credit
for next time he said yeah um and then
he wanted to set it up oh well keep your
boyfriend away though next time or
something like that so he was still like
setting and then I think that next time
was like the time that he killed her he
killed her yeah but um but yeah so she
I'm pretty sure that that was because I
knew one of the victims had done that
I'm pretty sure she was gonna go through
it this through it the second time I
wonder why she just go through with it
the first time I don't know maybe he's
gonna kill for the first time anyway
that's what yeah if that's what I mean
it's funny how she ran she set him up
the first time but then the second time
she was gonna say yeah you got credit
come on back
yeah that's right maybe maybe she maybe
she just tried
yeah tried to get out of it maybe and
she's like oh well he's Gonna Keep
pastoring Me might as well just let him
let him hit it's probably that's what it
was yeah Ben said did they find any of
these phones in his possession I don't
think they found any of the girls phones
but they found one of his burner phones
it was in his pocket
when they arrested him
I think it was the one that he used the
T Hawk email for I think that was the
one that was in his pocket if I remember
correctly and that was one that he had
used I believe to contact some of the
victims back then so he did keep some of
them for a while I guess but he would
keep them and like do illegal activity
on them but they were able to link them
all so like I said there's a huge it's
it's 32 pages and they have like this
huge list of like all the times where
the cell phones were and like the victim
cell phones like you know before they
disappeared and then there's like
activity on the victim's cell phones
like after they knew they were already
dead
that kind of [__] and it was in the same
place as he was and everything so once
they got all that info they you know
they needed more they went back through
the DNA stuff they're like okay well now
that we have a suspect we can test all
this DNA evidence like I said it was
mostly hairs they found like female
hairs and they found I believe one male
hair on one of the bodies
so what they did was they put the
[__] under surveillance and then
they did pretty much like what they did
with golden state killer they waited
until he threw something away and then
they swooped in there and got it now
what they did at first
um because three of the bodies had
female hairs on there
and so they went out when no one was
home and they took a bunch of bottles
out of the um trash
and they tested them and it turned out
that like I said the DNA was belonged to
uh Rex huerman's wife Asa
and then one of the male hairs or you
know with 90 what was it
98.69 certainty I think that's what it
was so they're like well you know we
can't say oh it's them but it's like you
know she is you know it's significant
that she can't be ruled out like even
though 99 of people on Earth can be
ruled out so they found that and then
when they tested the male hair
um that I think was stuck in like some
of the duct tape or something
um they that was they couldn't rule out
Rex huerman again 98 point I think it
was 98.69 if I'm remembering correctly
so it's like so obviously their hairs
are found uh on the body so that's a
little bit weird like I said they don't
think that the wife was involved they
don't think she knew anything about it
it was just transfer it was either
transferred from his clothing or his car
or the house or whatever
um you know which happens which I can't
even imagine that's got to be even
[__] but you know it's bad enough
that this woman has been married to this
[__] for 25 years finds out not only
has he been like [__] hitting sex
workers while she's away but
he's also killing them like in a
horrible way and looking at like all
this horrible porn and [__] like that
and you know and then it's bad enough
just like and then my hair was on the
dead bodies I can't imagine how I would
feel about that I just can't imagine and
I just feel really really bad but yeah
so just to be sure
another thing they did was they're like
okay so we wanted to do
you know we wanted to be even more sure
with the with the DNA thing even though
we had one of his hairs we were pretty
sure was his and three hairs which were
pretty sure his wife's that they got out
of their home garbage but what they did
they put him under surveillance they're
like watching him and then they noticed
he came out and they have video of it
because I saw it on YouTube
he came out his office in Manhattan and
he had ordered a pizza for lunch and it
looked like he ate most of the whole
thing because you know what I mean he's
a big boy and and he threw the pizza box
in a garbage can like outside of his
office on Fifth Avenue and so the cops
swooped in and got it and they um they
basically took DNA swab off the pizza
crust that he had taken a bite out of
and then they matched it and it's funny
because DJ Maniac he sent me like the
other night he sent me I guess it was
like a tweet or something like that it
was just like you know the Long Island
serial killer being caught by like a
[__] piece of pizza is the most Long
Island [__] in the like history of Block
Island which it really is and like I
mean they didn't catch him because of
that they already probably knew it was
him but they were just like making sure
so they did because they wanted to say
it's like okay that's his pizza we just
saw him put it in the [__] they were
filming him like put it in the I wanted
to make sure they got him got him good
exactly and and like I said
too much evidence on him there's no way
to get out that's what I'm saying that's
and it's always five times what they
need yeah
and well that's what I'm saying I think
that's why they spent so long because
they're like look we wanted to
um you know they've been working on this
since like January I think or February
of 2022. so they've been working on it
for a year more than a year and they're
like we just wanted to make sure that we
had everything like before we sweeped in
and got them but like I said they wanted
to sweep in and got them soon because
they knew from his phone records and
it's like that because they had him
under surveillance I don't think he knew
he was under surveillance but um but
they knew that he was still contacting
sex workers and they're like well this
um it implies to us that he might be
getting ready to kill again so we really
need to like get him off the [__]
Street before something bad happens
guarantee you you go down to Vegas
in that house and he's got in Vegas
there's more burner phones down there
I'm kind of suspect yeah when I read
that Ben says did they have a warrant to
seize the pizza you do not need a
warrant to seize someone's garbage if
it's in a public place yeah yeah um I'm
pretty sure you don't even need a
warrant if you like they can take your
garbage if you put it out on the yeah
it's down the street because once you
put the garbage out on the street it's
considered like public property yeah
it's no longer yours and he um and he
threw the pizza box out like it was in a
garbage can like on the street like in
New York City so that's public property
so you can't uh do anything about that
this isn't his only hunting ground it
can't be it's wherever he goes and does
time away from his wife that he's doing
this
I he yeah and I Vegas is the perfect
place that's what I was thinking and
there's a lot of unsolved murders out
there Vegas is full of hookers
and they come in from out of state
they tour a lot
[__] and uh they tour in and they'll
they'll run ads
through like that website I was telling
you about and they'd be like yeah I'm
gonna be in this area if you search that
area I'll be in this area between these
dates and the profile links back to them
because they
they're like a it's like a rock band
they go on tour
and uh
so that'd be a good place to hunt if
you're a serial killer and then you've
got all those deserts
easy to get rid of bodies out it does
yeah you can get [__] you can find a
place that's very secluded and you said
he's he had an avalanche a Chevy Chevy
Avalanche that's what he had of New York
he's probably got something like that
some kind of something like a Bronco or
a Jeep
it's probably what he's got down there
in
in the southwest and he could ride that
across the sand
and uh bury him out there or just dump
them that's what I mean and they
probably never find that no not a heater
get to it heat will get to it quick
and uh
it'll just be a bag of bones
in a burlap sack if it's in burlap
in a few days that's what he did with
those four that's what those were like
really similar the ones that the ones
from earlier that they found like a
little farther away
um some of those were buried the Gilgo
four they're pretty sure like I said
that most of these were probably him
um the Gilgo 4 they're just like I said
they have the most those are the most
similar to each other they were found
very close together
um you know and there's the most
evidence in those cases but he didn't
even bury them he just he put them in a
bag and like I said I don't know if
you've seen probably you've seen
pictures of the place like Gilgo Beach
like where these places it's very it's
on Long Island but it's really remote
um there's just like a long road called
Ocean Parkway and then there's kind of
houses but then there's like all this
like real thick Marshland
and like underbrush and stuff so
basically what he would do is he would
just go a little way off the Parkway and
just dump the bag yeah and nobody would
see it yeah so and it would just lay out
there it's like obviously it laid out
there for like well some of the bodies
um one of the girls disappeared in 2007
and they didn't find her until 2010. so
it laid out there for three years yeah
because not I mean people live out there
but it's pretty remote and it's just
real thick like nobody walks through
there it's funny uh
maybe I shouldn't say that what
I don't want to give anybody [__]
ideas
I'm sure they probably already have
ideas yeah
they shouldn't have even put it in the
bag
you know you're just throwing it out
taking a bag off of it once it was there
the animals if I could get it and
Scatter it maybe he thought that the bag
would like camouflage it more because
like I said all the Reeds and stuff out
there are kind of the same color as
burlap yeah so he thought it was more
like that would just keep everything
together I feel like this is what I this
is my suspicion
I think that the other bodies that they
found on like out on Ocean Beach like a
little farther away like peaches and
cherries and Valerie Mack and Jessica
Taylor and the baby baby doe
um and the unnamed Asian man they don't
they haven't identified him either
which is sad like a lot of the victims
aren't even identified Valerie Mac got
identified in
2018 prior to that she was also a Jane
Doe but um
I think that he started out dumping the
bodies there because I think he totally
did those two those six out there
I think that he started out there and he
buried them
and then I think that after a little
while went by he was like [__] it why
why do all that work like why bury them
because burying a body is work you know
what I mean he's like I could probably
just put him in a bag and throw him in
the weeds and no one would even see him
and he was right so that's why I'm
thinking that's why I'm thinking about
Vegas
you guys that maybe new to the show
I conducted military operations out in
desert environment the Sinai Peninsula
in Egypt or outside Egypt
we did desert patrols there
through a [__] on a four by four and
Jimmy 4x4 that was our Patrol vehicle
most of us during the day but we would
also drive around at night to do other
stuff
deliver things deliver surprise supplies
desert desert environments [__]
beautiful it's easy to operate at night
you don't even need night vision goggles
you can drive a truck around with the
headlights off and just black totally
blacked out
and if you pretty much know that area
okay you know you know what what the
mate what the terrain features are like
you can hit 45 miles an hour and just
drive it across the desert and not get
not do anything like fall into a ravine
so he was probably driving around at
night but the lights off and then just
tossing them out and then going back to
the road that he that he that you know
what I mean going back to the main road
that'd be a good place
with all those hookers yeah there's
going to be a bunch more victims down as
soon as I heard I think I heard like I
just heard it like three or four hours
ago
um like I saw it on on a news thing on
YouTube or something and as soon as they
said oh he had property in Vegas I was
like oh [__] and I imagine over over a
period of maybe 30 or 40 years there's
probably thousands
of missing girls they went missing out
of Vegas I mean I remember writing about
a few cases like unsolved murders in
Vegas because it's a very well it's kind
of like Florida in that way where it's
just like a lot of transient
a transient population
um you know it's a high tourism area
it's a high crime area a lot of people
are in and out known for prostitution
yeah it's also known for prostitution
like a lot of people go out there
specifically for that yeah the casinos
they work out of the casinos so I would
be shocked if he hadn't committed some
crimes out there I I would be shocked
it's impossible it's not possible that
he didn't commit crimes out there I yeah
because I don't think there's any way
because look he's 59 years old most
serial killers I'm not saying that it's
like it has to be this but most serial
killers start fairly young you know what
in their 20s or even like their late
teens
so I kind of feel like it would be very
unusual if he had started being a serial
killer just in the 50s no in his 50s or
in his 40s because I guess like some of
the victims a couple of the victims they
found on uh Long Island went back to
2003 and I think too that they're
they're maybe maybe trying to link him
before from like 1996. so this [__]
started in his teens I suspect that so I
suspect that there's a lot more I could
probably go back to his late teens and
he's probably doing sexual assaults
there may be a murder back in his early
teens probably and then and then Mike
quit for a few years and then in his 20s
he starts ramping it back up he's under
stress he starts ramping it up and then
he's probably a sex addict too
yeah I would he sounds like that too
sounds like Yeah from everything you
told me he's probably a sex addict also
as a [__] real seder and he's real um
sadistic and he's got to have this he's
got a lord over these women
there's a certain kind of woman he's
looking for I would really like to see
photographs of the ones that he did
business with and Let Live and the ones
that he killed I bet you there's a
visual difference between him
I bet you there's a certain look
it's a certain thing he's looking for
I mean he's seen by looking at the
photographs of the ones that he killed
they all look like Girl Next Door types
yeah and like I said they're all very
small too I think that's kind of one
thing because he was also into kids he's
kind of a little bit of a yeah that
makes me think that something happened
in his childhood too he's part of him is
kind of Frozen in childhood
uh something happened back there that's
[__] him up and that's also another
thing that that's another kind of person
that he could have total power over a
little kid yeah so
that's even to an extreme
but I bet I bet you know
I bet the ones that he let live were
rougher looking and looked more like a
hooker
he probably would do business with him
but he he's really wasn't turned on by
him
he didn't feel like he had to punish him
there's something about punishment in
this
yeah he really seems to be that kind of
[__] like I said you know
considering all the Google searches he
did like I said you can find it pretty
easily there's like a huge list of all
the things like he Google searched yeah
it's kind of he's gonna approach it from
the attitude of like well you're a good
girl and you've been bad so I'm gonna
punish you
but then if he sees one that just looks
like a [__] he's like oh you're just
beautiful you're all right
maybe yeah maybe that could be something
like that well I kind of feel like we've
talked about this before but I feel like
a lot of serial killers of this illness
Madonna have the Madonna horror complex
and that's how they can compartmentalize
that's how because I because it freaks
me out too like BTK or people like that
you know they have wives who apparently
don't know what's going on and they you
know 99 of the time would not even
imagine like doing anything to their
wife yeah because they class them as a
different kind of person kind of person
that's why he's calling the victims
families did you know that she was a
hooker now he's punishing them
say y'all should have known
yeah it's almost kind of like he's
extending the blame out we're like like
he's making them feel responsible for
her life choices of course of course
yeah of course and he gets off on doing
that yeah which is [__] up yeah that's
[__] up yeah and she got what was
coming to her you know it was gonna
happen that's his that's his ticket
say
she just got what she deserved
she was bad the thing about these dudes
too is that a lot of them are they seem
like they get off on I mean they get off
on thinking about sex workers they get
off on that but it's like that then
they're kind of like repelled and like
ashamed yeah too in a little bit which
makes them like act out and like
horribly violent ways I think that's
good they see themselves as honest right
and then they see these they see these
hookers as dishonest they're doing
something bad
they should be getting married they
shouldn't be taking money for sex it's
going to be just like that and really
what it is is kind of like jealousy see
he's a Seder he wishes he could go out
and get people to pay him to have sex
with them but nobody's
women don't pay for sex
especially not with that dude no the
dude like that so she has not with
anybody but I'm just saying especially
now with that yeah so in his mind she's
breaking the rules she's got an unfair
advantage over him
yeah she can sell sex and I can't I'm
gonna punish that [__] it's like that
so it's kind of like jealousy yeah and
she's exactly the opposite he is he's
big and kind of offishing ugly like an
ogre what they said and they're little
and cute
yeah and he can't stand it can't stand
it no hates him
that's what yeah I think he might be
you're probably onto something of course
yeah I understand the evil that lurks
within the hearts of men
well what it is is you just take normal
Base Animal emotions right and then you
just kind of twist them and make them
more extreme that's what it is it's just
going to be that
you should probably you should probably
be a serial killer profiler you probably
are good at that baby yeah yeah I
probably could
you gotta you have to have what's called
strategic empathy you have to be able to
stand in the shoes of the enemy and find
what they value most and what makes them
tick and how they see the world
that's why people fail a lot when
they're in conflicts with other people
they can't even describe the value
systems of their enemies all right they
just well they're bad oh they're bad
yeah what do they believe what are they
looking for I I I just bad stuff you
know they don't even know because they
can't put themselves in that person's
they don't have any empathy for the for
evil or whatever well that's why that's
why I always argue it's like I know that
there's a certain type of person that is
always kind of like on people about you
know why why are you like uh talking
about serial killers and why are you
trying to humanize serial killers like
talking about their terrible childhoods
and stuff like that I said it's not so
much that I'm trying to human I mean
they are humans you're trying to like
understand them you're trying to
understand where they're coming from
where did it all go wrong why are they
doing that it's like and I think that's
a really we should be doing that yeah
and they're not normal
obviously they're not normal this is not
normal behavior
um but obviously we need to know why
people are are doing it oh a lot of
their thought processes are within the
normal realm though but they're kind of
like normal for a child like for a child
like an angry child or an animal you
know which actually no animals are a
little more pure they're a little more
honest they don't they don't deceive
enough
humans will deceive themselves and
everyone else about what they're after
yeah because they always have a
justification yeah yeah they always have
adjusted animals don't bother they're
just no I want treats
no I want [__]
and like sometimes they'll do bad stuff
to get it yeah yeah like knock [__] over
in the middle of the night and make a
bunch of noise or like jump on your face
hide some or hide something I ate it no
I hate that one give me another I don't
like leftovers
Pookie doesn't like leftovers yeah but
but yeah but but like you said they just
do it they're not malicious they're not
malicious they're just doing it because
they want some so I think I think that's
what it is is uh you know he's he's
punishing them
out of jealousy yeah it might be that um
I was I was watching uh good old Dr
Grande who I really like him he gets it
man he must never sleep because as soon
the minute like some new new story comes
out about some criminal or some [__]
like that he's got a [__] video up
about that show like the next [__]
day like analyzing the dude like
everything she that he knows about
but um yeah he's basically saying the
same thing he's saying um you know
obviously uh very controlling very you
know anal retentive yeah
um aggressive of several people did say
he was aggressive although some people
said that he was real quiet reclusive
very unfriendly oh another thing I
didn't mention was that he had no
criminal record at all
no criminal record at all uh the only
thing that they brought up they said
that he in the last few years
he remember I said that he owed all this
money and back taxes well he had filed
for I believe it was four lawsuits in
New York state claiming that various
people had hit him with their cars I
don't know if he means that they hit him
while he was a pedestrian or they hit
him
I I'm thinking probably that because
that would be it would be harder to
prove like a car on car accident like if
you didn't have the police involved and
[__] but if somebody just hit you with
their car but he's trying to sue people
because he said that they had hit him
with their cars and like you know caused
all kinds of like injuries and stuff and
as far as I know three of those cases
were either dismissed or settled but one
of them is still ongoing I suspect like
I was listening to another thing where
it was talking about this
is what he was trying to do was he was
gonna try and make all this money like
from these lawsuits and then he was
gonna go to South Carolina and like
retire out there and
I'm curious to see like when they
because I'm as far as I know they're
searching that property in South
Carolina too that he owns with his
brother I don't know what if I don't
know if it's a cabin or if it's a house
or if it's Acres or anything like that
but I don't think they're gonna find
anything there maybe well they have to
search though yeah I bet you they won't
find anything there because if he left
anything there and be afraid his brother
would find it unless his brother was in
on it
I doubt but I doubt it yeah
um I mean I have I I did listen to one
thing that kind of like brought up that
possibility
um and on that I think it was uh the
channel was Grizzly True Crime she's
like a grizzly bear
um she's like a South African woman
and she has done like a [__] ton I
couldn't listen to them all because they
were really long but I listened to like
a few hours that she did about it
because she did a bunch of videos about
it and she said
that she'd read somewhere that I think
this happened in South Carolina
that Rex and his brother Craig were
there and someone like their neighbor or
something like that was mowing their
lawn I think was how it was going and
Craig came out
and hit the guy in the back of the head
like with a metal pole like saying I
didn't want you to mow the lawn today or
something like that like it was some
kind of situation like that I don't know
if that really happened but I'm just
saying that that was something else that
I heard so she was kind of saying that
it's like oh you know that's kind of
weird like so we don't know we don't
know what their family Dynamic was like
as far as I know he only has the one
brother
and I don't really know about
his parents
I've heard it mentioned but it's like I
don't you know I don't know if there's
like much going on there so I don't know
if he was abused or anything like that I
mean it doesn't necessarily have to have
been abused because some serial killers
weren't I mean obviously some of them
were really horribly but
a lot of them weren't too A lot of them
just had like regular childhoods and
still were [__] up that's why I kind
of think that it always has to be a
combination of factors and some of those
factors are genetic I'm sure because
some people
can be born and endure all kinds of
horrific abuse like as children and
still turn out okay like not become
serial killers I was just sitting there
I'm taking a leak thinking that [__]
was crazy that she's letting those
clients go to her house doing in-calls
at her house I can't understand why the
hell his escorts do that
I would never be scared too well I'd
never let those dudes know where I lived
I I mean I would never do that anyway
because it's like I mean I understand
why people do it
because it's you know a lot of money and
it's like something that you can do
if you don't really have a lot of skills
to do yeah yeah but um you know so and
people get desperate I get that but but
why do an end call why why let them come
to your house
you don't want to go to their house
that's what I mean it's like I always
kind of feel like there's really the
well the thing about it though is that
like there's no Safe Place Hotel I guess
but it's like you know they could still
[__] murder you in there maybe maybe
she felt safer at her own house maybe
there's roommates there or something is
then they know where you live right and
then they can kind of follow you while
you leave or some [__] like that well
like I said maybe maybe she lived with
other people and maybe she felt safe
because there was people around all the
time maybe like so maybe she's like well
I don't want to go to a hotel because
it's like gonna be a bunch of strangers
and well no I think what it is is that
the hotel is extra money for the client
so you lose a lot of your clients
because they have to spend the extra
hundred dollars for the hotel room
so that cuts a lot of the business right
probably
so if you offer them an in-call option
whether you can come to them you can
come to her house
it saves you it saves the client money
you get more you get more movement more
of them come
but still the more I'm going to come the
more risk there is because yeah
you know maybe only one out of a hundred
is a [__] nut
I think more than one out of 100 would
be a nut uh yeah big time I would think
probably about
25 percent of it would be some kind of
nut maybe not necessarily dangerous but
just
yeah somebody you know that you wouldn't
really want us
it might be a higher percentage than
that no you can bring it up now ala
who's she's famous hooker she's all over
YouTube she says the best thing to do
girl girls is uh should do is just raise
their prices which cuts out all the
young guys and nothing but senior
citizens and that's what she so she's
1800 for the first hour
I mean you can't blame her yeah yeah
that's gonna weed out a lot but she's
famous now right you know what I mean so
she can ask that's celebrity pricing
but you go on like that one app that I
talked about that once it's an app
you'll see and it's a fascinating app
she recommended it
you can you can actually profile an
entire area
you could say you know everything 30
miles from this location like you you
put down the whatever look it's you know
might be useless or whatever and you
could profile your whole area as to what
the hell's going on there in terms of
income
the lower those prices are the more
[__] up the girls look the worse that
area is you can tell if it's a
collapsing area or a growing area yeah
just by well that's the thing like I
said the girls that are working it's
like they're wherever they're stuck at
they're gonna have to like adjust their
prices to the clientele right and if the
clientele around there don't have any
[__] money and you need to get their
money then you can't afford to charge
right a thousand dollars because no
one's got it not a nice Suburban urban
areas nicer cities about 900.
all right and that's about it it seems
like that's about what these escorts
were making back in 2009 2010 when they
were working and if she's fine like a
model looking in that area 13.
you know and in that air same area if
you see girls are like a 300
you don't want anything to do with that
nasty
yeah
but in other areas 300 400
might be a lot better because in that
area there's not there's no income the
income is lower
so it's weird you can kind of profile an
area
yeah it's always has to do with like
that yeah and it's kind of interesting
their profiles to read their Pro and see
what tactics they're using you know me
and Jenny doing stream mating [__] you
you want to know every angle
it's like a carnival like these are like
carnies yeah and it's a very organized
subculture and how they do it which is I
think part of the reason why dudes like
this target them because they kind of
they kind of [__] infuriated by the
organization involved it's another it's
a subculture yeah and uh they're like
that's not that's not normal well [__]
they're all [__] kinda
in a community hey working's working so
they all have to know each other in the
area those girls all know each other in
the area yeah well like I said that's a
good thing because it's like they're
watching shows they can watch each
other's backs yeah because that's like I
said that's a very dangerous line of
work yeah and they're not Street walking
I mean there's in some places but that's
real low end [__] yeah I mean that's
like super desperate yeah [__]
it's all online now
Twitter had a lot of it that's the main
place to find them and then they [__]
once you know what you're looking at you
understand the code words they're
talking about it leads back to profiles
that you can call them on
and you'd be surprised man [__] you
don't know who those people actually are
for all you know you know
she's married and the husband knows
there's a lot of that
um
uh some of the some of the girls are
just like family type girls that nobody
knows they're doing that
well it does seem that like after these
particular women were killed um I don't
think their family most of their
families knew what they were up to
I don't think they do well because I
mean they were adults so they weren't
living at home anymore
um you know but they don't have that sex
worker Viber look to a lot of them
which I think is part of their marketing
appeal well like I said some of them had
like regular jobs they were just trying
to make extra money yeah just side shift
and a lot of the ones that are expensive
like that but are very selective they're
just trying to weed out younger guys
they don't want them
they want guys that are 65 plus married
with a lot of money business owners
like they want to be in trouble yeah but
see that just goes to show yeah even if
you go with that angle probably safer
but he's one of those never entirely
safe yeah yeah he was one of those
that's what I mean on paper he would
seem
not necessarily a threat right because
he was older he owned a business yeah
you know he's he had a family like he
seemed like a normal dude well according
to Ayala the younger ones she she threw
them out not because
they were dangerous per se physically
it's just that they were too much of a
hassle yeah I can see that uh that they
didn't want to pay those prices and that
they didn't want to like they didn't
think they got their money's worth that
type of thing yeah they're probably
always pissing them they're like oh man
that was [__] [__] but the older
guys are just happy to have company
well thank you you know well yeah you
want somebody that's going to appreciate
you yeah and these dudes are chumpy okay
I've seen the profiles of the dudes
they're mostly chompy
which like I said that's what they're
looking for yeah but this it's funny
because this dude was like that type
yeah but he was a killer but he was a
serial killer so like I said you never
know never can't tell yeah you're
probably safer yeah generally it's with
older dudes statistically yeah but
you're never 100 safe you never know
you'd be statistically safer with but
you never know well like I said BTK was
like that too it only takes one now
these guys are rare
right
dangerous guys are probably more
prevalent in the younger section
yeah that that is also a serial killer
it'd be just something to beat yep and
not paying you're taking your money and
robbing you yeah you know and those are
generally we've talked about that before
I'm not saying that it's better but I'm
just saying that it's kind of two
because um somebody mentioned earlier
that it's like um how I said that a lot
of serial killers that had wives and
like the wives didn't know and I kind of
feel like a lot of the times the serial
killer wouldn't kill their wife because
they had compartmentalized like this
isn't the same type it's not acceptable
yeah like to kill her because she's a
different type of person but um but I so
I kind of feel like and then he said
well what a when a wife gets killed like
99 of the time it's the husband which
yes it usually is that's why they always
investigate the husband of the boyfriend
first because statistically that's who
it's most likely to be strangely serial
killers aren't killing their wives but
yeah but so yeah because I think that
there are two different it's a different
deal it's a yeah it's two different
might it's still bad obviously that's
it's you know equally horrible but it's
two different mindsets I kind of feel
like serial killers tend to be a lot
more you know they plan things they tend
to go after strangers uh things like
that whereas you know people that kill
their spouses or their family I mean
that's usually
I mean sometimes that's planned too but
that's usually kind of like
after like a long time it's like oh I
can't stand her anymore or she did
something to piss me off or whatever or
that it's an abuse situation yeah so I
kind of feel like it's that the engine
they're talking about Sir that the law
enforcement are usually fumbling and
can't catch people actually what's funny
is that recently
um if you kind of look
I don't think the cut at least in the
state of Florida
they'll go after massage parlors that
are [__] undercover [__]
rubbing tugs they'll go after them
but they don't seem to care about
anything happening online it seems to be
that's too expensive and difficult to
police
and they don't care as long as it's not
in public I really think they don't care
now
as long as it's probably not I mean even
though technically it's still illegal
yeah they just wanted to be out in
public they don't want Street Walkers
well and it's just so it's and it's so
ubiquitous yeah that I feel like even if
you wanted to stop it I don't think you
could at this point yeah it's just like
performance enhancing drugs and steroids
and [__] technically in a lot of States
that's illegal but they'll never
actually take action on them unless it's
an underground lab why cops take them
a lot of cops take them they don't care
the money's not there there isn't any
there isn't a violent drug scene
surrounding that
you know they don't they have a problem
with fentanyl Okay so
they just don't have the money or the
resources or The Willpower to go after a
lot of this stuff
serial killers [__] will jump on it
they'll jump on these girls took it
because because you can get your hands
on them well like I said it's yeah like
I said it's easy yeah all you have to do
is like call them up and set up a date
you can do it right you know and they'll
come right to you yeah and if you're one
of these Punisher types like this guy
then that you're looking for the girl
that needs to be punished the good girl
that's doing wrong she should have known
better that's the thinking I think yeah
that seems like yeah that track she
looks like a total hoe he's like yeah
okay he'll accept that
it's one that is deceptive I think in
his mind uh she shouldn't be doing this
I might punish her yeah because that's
what he's doing yeah because I looked I
looked at those girls and I was going
like they don't have that they don't
have the Working Girl look
which a lot of those working girls who
go you look like that they look like
that on purpose because they don't want
to look like
professional
because older guys will go with the one
go with go for the ones that don't look
like professionals younger guys that go
for the ones that just look extremely
hooker they're like oh yeah yeah it's
hot they'll go after that
because it's the thrill of it
but I think the older guys are
reminiscing from an ER reminiscing or
Nostalgia for an earlier era in their
life where they could actually like get
wet get laid without having to pay with
that pay it exactly the young guys
[__] as Jacks that he's paying for it
it's instant on demand
just like ordering a pizza
she better have some big ass daddies
that short that that skirt better be
short as [__] when you show up because
it could be [__] like that yeah
exactly yeah I get it yeah
I mean dudes aren't really that hard
enough to be nice
just think of the dumbest [__] you can
think of and that's probably it well you
know I was pretty open about it on a
show when I was in Korea you know I mean
that's all we had access to was
professional Korean chicks they had a
whole Army of them and then in the
nightclubs down there and they were all
legalized in the [__] US Army [__]
checked them all out the Medics checked
them all out and everything they all had
cards and everything they were just Club
Club call girls and [__] we we were
in [__] Hog Heaven man [__] uh we
only got like we only got like one day
off a month
you know
you gotta do a lot of [__] on that
one day yeah man and they were cute man
they were nice and um we were just and
and man [__] they look like hookers
we loved it yeah just some [__]
cowgirl outfit so [__] short shorts
on and [__] cap guns and [__] girl
heavy metal girls and just anything that
anything to [__] that would appeal
Americans guys yeah that's what they
were doing the Cowboys they had someone
look like rappers and [__] you know
please tell me they had one that dressed
like the Statue of Liberty no no no no
[Laughter]
they're like well could you
that's kind of my finish yeah that would
be like super funny though they just had
one in there like [__] sore
hysterical except like a sexy Statue of
Liberty oh my God that'd be a good
Halloween costume I don't think I've
seen anybody do it but it was over there
over there it was a good scene that was
up on hooker up on hooker Hill and
itaewang
yeah they stopped all that now they made
it they made all they made it illegal we
evidently went underground and it's just
foreign girls doing it now like girls
from Eastern Europe and
Philippines evidently that's that's who
took over the Korean girls they got
banned from it
and they were mad they were having whole
demons
I heard about all this [__] later they
were doing [__] walks and protests the
girls the Korean girls
because they weren't being allowed back
into society see this is the thing
that was all government-backed Korean
government-backed the Korean government
was basically recruiting and training
girls and even teaching them English to
speak English to be
the prostitutes in these clubs in this
one section
their mission was was to pick up any
rumors that they heard so it was it
Intel yeah okay
and
to make as much to get as much of the
gi's
[__]
pay into the Korean economy yeah so
they're getting your paycheck out of the
[__] American Soldier and putting in
the Korean economy they were helping
rebuild in their economy right and you
know as successful as South Korea is
right now A lot of it was on the back of
that
if it the interaction between does
anybody appreciate all those girls right
well you see the thing is when they
recruited them they were telling them
this is like a patriotic Duty we had an
army of American guys down there
protecting them from the North Korea and
an army of [__] South Korean girls
there to get all their money that's what
and entertain them yeah to keep them
from bothering the locals
well when all that [__] shut down they
were out of work and it ain't no got
none of the guys over there wanted to
marry him anymore because they're all
busted out right oh yeah you've been
[__] them foreigners and they didn't
want them so uh they I don't know what
happened to them but they were they were
big protests
I felt sorry for him you know because in
a way that's like
that's like the
Soldiers the oldest professions hookers
the the second oldest professional
soldiers they're both selling their
bodies to Old Men that's what they're
doing essentially yeah just at one of
them's for sex and the other ones to
kill the Old Man's enemies
yeah that's what it is I really wish
better now than it used to be but I I
would really like to see in my lifetime
the stigma surrounding sex work to
disappear it does seem like it's going
in that direction but I don't know the
stigma will never disappear they'll just
uh they'll just be able to decriminalize
it
which they should decriminalize it'll
make a lot safer I think it would all
right but but here's the thing you don't
want it to become so legal where
corporations get involved no no then
you'll have chains of brothels and then
[__] huge advertising campaigns to
get your [__] daughter to work in
there and it should be a last resort
women shouldn't want to be hookers I
mean some people want to do it and
that's fine
um but I do kind of feel I mean probably
I don't know what the percentage is but
I think most of the women that do it
they end up doing it here this is this
is like I don't think they chose it
necessarily no this is my thinking on it
any sex work in general
kinda [__] up a younger woman's choices
in the future if she's ever going to
look for a family yeah you can find a
boyfriend and a husband Maybe
but even women that haven't don't have
that in their past have a problem
it's just one more thing kind of against
you to eliminate certain guys
now there are some guys that are into
that but do you want to go over that guy
who's into that maybe that's a fetish I
don't know
and me and Jen are kind of you know in
in we do streamate we make video product
and [__] like that
which is selling well I know you guys
are buying that [__] up on streambate
uh but anyway uh
I don't recommend it for young people
I'd recommend it more for a woman who's
already had a family or a kid or
whatever you know she's in her 30s or
40s maybe she's divorced
it's not gonna be held against her too
much as much not as much as not as much
because she's not in her prime breeding
getting married age she's now and now
she is old enough and people know she
knows what she's doing she's more what
you would call Seasoned and empowered
and here's the thing here's a weird
thing a lot of Jenny's fans are young
young guys like older women that are
sexy like that and they make a much
better porn star if you ask me or if
they were going to be an escort yeah you
want them like 35 Plus
you know who's lived a normal life
she might have a kid or so you know what
I mean that'd be better because she you
know
if they get into that involved in that
[__] in their late teens or whatever man
you're kind of denying them a normal
life a normal life as a young person
yeah I mean once you've already had kind
of a normal life I'm like [__] it I'm
just gonna go yeah you're strong enough
to do it yeah then yeah yeah that
probably that's probably healthier a lot
healthier because you know who you are
you have a stronger identity by that
time yeah that's true yeah and uh you
know you you your Skin's a lot thicker
yeah that's true yeah I just I don't
recommend it for young people
yeah it might come back and bite you in
the ass later like I said it's not as
the stigma isn't as bad as it used to be
but there still is a stigma yeah
um and yeah if you have that in your
past like you know when you're looking
for jobs or something like that like
later on if you decide to go straight or
whatever you want to call it yeah um you
know somebody might find that [__] and
be like yeah we're not hiring this
person you know what I mean so yeah
you're 27. some check here to look great
and [__] you meet this [__] 35 year
old guy he's [__] loaded he [__]
loves you to death and [__] and he finds
out you're a hooker no you're gone he's
not gonna marry you
you're not gonna bury you yeah
uh James homie Holmes says I swear this
dude was not the only one doing this I
remember hearing about some law
enforcement connections to some of the
women that were murdered so it could be
multiple or he's a Fall Guy I don't
think he's necessarily A Fall Guy
however
there was
um and I think we talked about this on
our show that we did about this in 2018
there was a cop what was his last name
he was a sergeant wasn't he Boyle I want
to say it was his last time I can't
remember what his last name was but he
was actually
um seemed like he was actively impeding
the investigation into the Long Island
serial killer so for a time he was
considered a suspect or a person of
interest I think that they dismissed him
eventually but he did get in trouble for
the
uh you know for the get in the way of
the investigation and stuff like that
like later on and I think that was
mostly to do with the Shannon Gilbert
case which like I said I'm not really
sure if that's even no one's really sure
if that's really related to the other
Long Island serial killers because they
still don't know if she died
accidentally or if she was murdered I
tend to think she was murdered but I'm
not entirely sure
and because the thing about it was I
don't know it just seems very weird to
me that she would just like wander off
and
it's not weird that she would drown in a
marsh I know that's like kind of like
harsh territory out there but the way
she was found like makes me suspect that
she was probably killed
um Mr 88 said and I'm kind of behind on
the comments very very few of the big
serial killers had completely normal
childhoods BTK is the only one I can
think of that didn't have a specific
well-known childhood stressor I was
there he just didn't talk about it yeah
well and he said too like um
wait a minute uh yeah James said BTK
didn't even talk about his problems
either the era he was born into was so
conservative it didn't allow for that
kind of sex talk dude had had the
ability to be normal and I've we brought
that up in a lot of cases before
particularly in the case of like Jeffrey
Dahmer people like that I think that had
they been born in a different era
um some of them might have turned out
okay and it's almost been turned out all
right if he was a teenager now
yeah I don't think if he was born now or
he was a teenager now I don't think he
would be a serial killer
um I don't know obviously we can't run
that experiment but dobber became a
serial killer to hide the fact that he
was gay
yeah which was not as acceptable back
then it was still seen as you made a
move on a guy that he invited over to
the house he was a teenager and he
killed him with a [__] barbell
because he [__] made a move and then
the guy says now I gotta do it I'm gonna
[__] with you you [__] boom then he
killed him yeah that was his first kill
that's that sent him down the road so he
killed people to hide the fact that he
was gay
then he went on to kill gay people
knowing that he was gay but it was just
part of his part of his sexual
appetite by that time he wanted total
control over a person he wanted living
sex doll he wanted them to never leave
he wanted to never leave didn't want
anybody to leave him alone with his
Insanity yeah he had some like bad
abandonment yeah so and he didn't want
him to be awake either though he wanted
to be like a living sex doll so he's
drilling holes in their heads putting
Drano in them and [__]
he was bizarre man what'd you even
thinking [__] crazy like I said I
write horror and I didn't ever thought
of that taking pictures of the [__]
dissected bodies and [__] making and
he's doing all this in his [__]
little apartment
yeah
because we had acid I mean we've made
the argument before that I think that
the reason you don't see the same types
of serial killers at least to the same
degree that you saw it say in the 70s
um or 80s is probably because of the
Advent or the Internet it's just easier
to
access
um you know if it's some kind of weird
sexual fetish or perclivity or something
like that it's pretty easy to find
something that will satisfy your needs
and other people that are into the same
[__] as you so you're not sitting there
all by yourself thinking I'm the only
person in the world that's into this and
I'm a [__] freak and you and you
can't find anybody else to
satisfy those urges you know what I mean
whereas nowadays it's very very easy you
just go on and be like hey is anybody
into whatever and it's like hey yeah
okay and then you can just find somebody
that's in the same [__] as you
so I think that that has alleviated a
lot of the things that would have caused
serial killers before and I think like
like you said like BTK like coming from
um from an era where
particularly I feel like you know during
the 50s and stuff like that where dudes
were not really supposed to talk about
how they felt like they were just
supposed to be real stoic and keep
everything inside and I really don't
think that that's a very healthy way of
going about things because you just
suppress a lot of [__] yeah
no I don't know I didn't say that I just
you know I think that was definitely a
factor it was just one of the factors
you had guys that had serious problems
and [__] uh they couldn't talk about
them
and also you were in a society where you
were really judged by what kind of
things you were into in terms of
sexually yeah and there wasn't an
internet back then to [__] let these
dudes know that hey it's not just you
there's a lot of dudes that are into
this [__] and go talk to them and see
it's not so weird and then they actually
work that kink out of them they're like
oh okay yeah and then I think a lot of
those dudes would have outgrown a lot of
those weird Kinks that they had if they
had access to the internet because they
just gotten tired of it yeah because
it's like you know it's very easy to
Blossom steam and then oh okay and then
they're like all right okay then they're
on to something else right but they were
kind of cloistered and [__] shut in
and it got worse and worse and worse it
started growing them like a cancer then
they started acting on it and then once
they act on it man they can't back off
of it it's now part of them
yeah because then it kills escalating
yeah they've killed somebody over this
so they can't back off of it now it's
now part of them that's why you see the
escalation because the serial killer
once they do one yeah and then it's like
well
you know they they'd probably been
fantasizing about that for a really long
time yeah and then they finally did it
and they're like now they did it but now
they have to keep like ramping it up
because it's not as good as the first
time I guess I don't know I'm not a
serial killer but they got a whole
online scene this has been going on
forever in the 90s I remember hearing
about it it gave me the Shivers back
then hearing about
this is back you know in the late 90s uh
when they were doing those weird [__]
fake cases we even know what they were
they're kind of like you you thought
they were telling you the truth but it
turned out that the whole thing was fake
uh what'd they call those things
it's like a puzzle
like a murder mystery and you thought it
was a murder that really happened but it
didn't happen they made it all up what
was that called you knew what they were
something used to be on the internet
back in the 90s
like kind of like a multimedia type
thing I don't know like like an ARG ARG
that's exactly what I'm talking about
ARG alternate reality game yeah during
those args
I can't divide when in that same era
came to my attention there was a group
of people online
called vores
they were fantasized about eating people
yeah and they would write up all kinds
of [__] they would just [__] man it
sounded like they really did like they
were really doing it
it was scaring the [__] out of me it
turned out it was all fantasy they were
just [__] writing that is it was just
there now here's the thing
I don't think he I don't think most of
those people didn't ever eat anybody no
but talking about it I think prevented
them from eating people if [__] that
it wasn't there
those dudes probably would have ate
somebody
see that's what I suspect because that's
a pretty that's a pretty out there
fetish okay I'm gonna say that right
it's been around a long time it has been
yeah people have been cannibalizing each
other remember Albert Fish yeah back in
the early 1900s or late 1800s eating
people and he was saying that well
people eat people in China all the time
and I thought he was bullshitting I went
back and checked said no they were
eating people in China too they were
eating they were selling little children
they were selling meat off of children
in in the open in certain places in
China at certain times because they were
just in a huge famine
and uh you know if people somebody died
they didn't waste it they'd they'd sell
the meat
that went on and up until the 80s during
that cultural revolution they were
eating people that they suspected of
being um
uh whatever just they would just accuse
people of being capitalists and they'd
eat them it's called a flesh banquet you
guys can check that up that happened and
the Communist party went down there to
investigate it and try to stop it and
they evidently did stop it but they um
they tried to hush it out but it got out
anyway they were just it's kind of like
their Red Guard which was kind of like
just
nowadays it'd just be like protesters
would just gag up and accuse people of
being
capitalists and then eat them
sounds insane
but they were insane I guess
uh but I thought that was fake but it is
true it's called a [__] flashback
with Chinese flesh banquet
crazy so there has been cannibalism
there's a lot of cannibalism in World
War II on the Eastern Front
especially an installing Grodd when it
got [__]
uh there was cannibalism all in in
um North Korea well the thing about it
is there's there's a difference between
cannibalism because you're starving and
cannibalism because you get off on it
yeah but I think they kind of go hand in
hand after a while I think some people
start sexualizing it well yeah of course
that's gonna happen and and I think
there was
um
people like that back in the 1800s
candles
and that was probably was kind of a
serial killer type deal
type thing
you know you know there's people they
were running ins and killing people and
stealing their luggage and [__] and
evidently probably eating people
like any free meat yeah
so who knows what goes through the minds
of people in the Victorian era
I I'd be horrified to know probably so
could be that things like the Vore seen
online actually kind of prevented
cases a few some cases of cannibalism
probably not a lot because there weren't
a lot of people in that scene right
but those particular people that stopped
that scene out were probably going to be
cannibals
had they not
talked about it it was like a talk
therapy I don't know I'm envisioning it
being like therapy
yeah and like I said I think that a lot
of the
you know we've talked about this before
like I said but I feel like a lot of the
people that kind of became
serial killers earlier like in the 60s
and 70s I think that was just because
they were brought up with these weird
fetishes or sexual proclivities and they
didn't have any outlet for it so it's
like we're nowadays like I said you
could talk to people about it or you
could make art of it and like you know
go on [__] websites and whatever and
you can there's like other people and
you can talk about it so it might I
don't think it's gonna stop everybody
from doing that because some people are
just going to do it regardless but I do
think that it helps though like this
dude he was searching weird porn terms
you know Katie proms
rape prawn
chances are you know he was already
doing that but chances are there was
like a placebo
yeah something to hold him over until
the next one that he could do yeah right
so there might be a lot of guys who want
to go out and do that but they never
actually get the balls to do it so they
just look at images images of fake rapes
yeah because that well see that's the
thing I kind of feel like a lot of the
Google searches that this dude did
um you know they're horrible but they're
not probably not all that unusual I
think a lot of dudes that are not serial
killers probably doing that too also
want to see you know prawn of women tied
up and like women getting beat up and
well that's fed FB BDSM right yeah right
so it's not that weird
um you know we've just seen just just on
a cursory glance through pron sites
seeing like stuff where like people are
crying like with dicks in their mouth
and it looks like people like praying
painful and stuff so the fact that he
was looking that up it's it's only
Sinister in context because you know
that he's probably a killer but he's
doing it for real but I kind of feel
like a lot of dudes look at that kind of
porn and don't ever kill them yeah
there's also the tone of it the girl
that she was talking about she was um
doing this to dildos
and slapping herself and crying and
[__] but she had whole stories made
up of what was happening
and it was actually [__] funny yeah
you could tell that she's like she's
just having fun with it so the tone has
a lot to do they wasn't credible yeah I
think he's more looking for stuff
realistic like snuff type [__] yeah yeah
[__] women that are bruised up and
[__] fat lips and [__] for being
[__] punched and [__] you know yeah
he specifically searched for a pretty
girl with bruises on yeah right now
there's [__] like that out there but
it's fake you can just use makeup to get
that effect yeah
um well hopefully I don't want any girls
to go and it's like hey beat up my face
but then there are some in the BDS team
scene where they'll [__] paddle the
ass black and blue hit them with they'll
yeah okay them and hit him with switches
and [__] and even draw blood
but she's she's uh she's consent of that
yeah right that that's her because she's
into that yeah right but see that's I
and I think that's why a lot of that
kind of stuff is sort of like a slippery
slope because you're not entirely sure
like whether that person was consented
to that or not you know what I mean you
can't really assign the release forms
and then they're starring in multiple
features I mean it depends where it
turns up is what I'm saying that's why
it's kind of like sometimes with amateur
porn you don't you're not really sure it
is because you're like you don't know
who this is and it's like you don't even
know in most reputable sites the it has
to be a known person
before we stream on streamate every
single time we have to like get in the
frame and they have to do like the 3D
mapping and [__] like that to make sure
that no unauthorized people are like in
the [__] [__] you know what I mean
first related to this the first customer
we ever had wanted me to [__] rough
her up slapping her and stuff I didn't
slap her as hard as he wanted me to I
negotiated that before I don't want it
between one and ten how hard you want me
to slap he's like nine I said no dude
nine I'd knock her out yeah the police
yeah no he's like
you know he's like you slap her as hard
as uh as hard as you feel comfortable
where it doesn't apparently hurt or
I said I said you want to do it she's
like yeah it would do it so we did it
well because I trusted you not to like
yeah because you're not good to my hand
yeah you're not getting my hands when I
slap her [__] they made a nice pop
but it was
mostly sound effects yeah it kind of
hurt but not really yeah not really uh
Jeff yard says I know quite a few people
who enjoy being sex workers both male
and female and of course not all women
or men want a traditional family with
kids yeah and that's what I mean and
people absolutely should have that uh
choice if they want to do that yeah I'm
just saying that if somebody came to me
for advice and they were 18 or 19 or
something and said hey I'm thinking
about getting into sex work I'd be like
well you can if you want but I would
recommend I wouldn't recommend it like
at that age like wait until you're a
little bit older like and get your [__]
together yeah he says well some people
and don't worry about it as much yeah
and here's another thing just because
some people like that job doesn't mean
that job's for everybody yeah I do [__]
that most people would never do okay
[__] I was doing it in the Infantry
they don't have the [__] mental
intestinal fortitude and they're not to
[__] that would [__] make your blood
curdle is to me is like looking at it
beautiful
bowl of ice cream or something I like
that kind of stuff you know what I mean
which is hard for me sometimes you know
so it's not for everybody it's the same
thing with
any kind of extreme profession requires
a certain kind of person for that
when when I talk when she says sex work
she's just talking about in general
she's talking about this only fans and
girls running their own little naughty
sites and [__] most of that's [__]
harmless all right
um but when
when I say sex first I'm usually talking
about hooking that's sex well yeah
that's kind of more the extreme I would
never recommend that to a young woman no
well no not that no
I mean even escorting I mean just just
because it's dangerous yeah well and
there's so many more Outlets nowadays if
you want to get into that without
getting your ass killed or just giving
you giving yourself a stigma like that
now if you're gonna do if you were gonna
be an escort or hook and that's the same
thing just different ways of different
descriptors
if you are going to do that you're a
woman you should do that later on
you know what I mean I mean do that when
you're old enough to know that you are
an advice yeah and you've already lived
your life as a young person you've had
all that you know what I mean and you're
now you know in your late 30s or early
40s and you're mature and you
you know what that you can do it and
it's right for you and it's not going to
impact your family life or whatever
uh in a very negative way then uh
I still wouldn't recommend it nurse
other things but if you want to do it
then it's a lot safer yeah
that's all I'm saying yeah
Victor says y'all should do a show about
people that fake their own kidnappings
or assaults Like Jesse smallett uh
Sherry papini yeah I remember that case
and that doctor that stabbed himself and
tied himself up oh yeah I remember that
I wrote it down I wrote it down
um I think for the next week's show I
think we're gonna do the killer mom show
because that's what wanted to poll this
last week but we preempted it so we
could talk about the this [__]
but um I'll put that in the next poll
though because that's actually a good
idea and I don't think we've I don't
think we've done one like that like
people that fake their own kidnappings
and that's like actually a really good
idea I'm super super behind on the
comments yeah John's talking about Max
Hardcore he went to prison for all that
[__] yeah what's funny about his
material is that his material would he
wouldn't have got in trouble for that
nowadays that was just
he was just [__] um
a jury decided that he was [__] that
it was obscenity so he did I think five
six years for that I think maybe more
but there's all kinds of material just
like that
out now
and nobody's going to jail over it was
just
victim of the time well yeah I mean like
I said there's so much of it out there
it's like it's really hard to prosecute
and in a way it's like
in a way I don't have a problem with the
proliferation but in another way I can
see how it's harder to
um
it's harder to keep track of you know
people that were possibly trafficked or
people that are underage or something
like that so I get why
you know even though it was a pain in
the ass for us like
doing uh you know streamate and
everything like that like you have to
jump through all these hoops and
everything but I get why they do that
they don't want to get in trouble they
don't want anyone on the site that
doesn't want to be on there uh you know
or is being forced to be on there or
isn't of age or whatever so you know
they so they do have protocols in place
but the thing about it is there's a lot
of sites out there too that don't
do that then don't check that and just
like we'll put up anything so I think
it's they're kind of cracking down but
I don't know but like I said it's it's
kind of hard because you can't
you know where'd that video come from
you don't know who that person is you
don't know how old they are you don't
know if they're being forced to do it or
whatever so I get it it's kind of like a
double-edged sword but I mean generally
I don't have a problem with porn or sex
work or whatever as long as everyone's
consenting and of age but
like I said I understand that it's kind
of hard too
sort that out nowadays because there's
so much of it out there
so let me see
um I think that I brought up everything
that I needed to bring up about this
[__]
because like I said
yeah I'm just looking he's what folks in
the kitty tree
poops in the kitty tree yeah yeah but
yeah so I was looking to see if there
was anything else that I needed to
mention about this Rex hillerman dude
I'm interested to find out more about it
more it's gonna come out well yeah
because like I said the dude literally
just got arrested Friday yeah and like I
said they just they they didn't want him
to know that they were working so they
were kept in motor surveillance for a
while and they're being super sneaky
about it and they didn't want to pick
him up at his house because he has a
[__] ton of guns and so they didn't know
if like the situation was gonna go
sideways so they wanted to get him
somewhere where he wasn't expecting it
so they actually arrested him and
there's uh there's footage of it you can
see it on YouTube
of them arresting him uh they just got
him when he was walking out his office I
think he was just going home for the day
or going to the train or whatever coming
out his office on Fifth Avenue and just
walking down the street and all of a
sudden like all these dudes like in
Black just kind of like surround him and
he's like what like he's he was totally
shocked yeah going sideways
they they weren't afraid that he was
going to shoot the cops he he wouldn't
do that what he would do is he would
kill himself
yeah he's one of those yeah they did the
control freak right they didn't want
that kind of situation he's a control
freak he would say they caught me okay
I'm out of here I ain't going to jail
that's what he would have done I wonder
and then he would Escape Justice yeah
that's pretty typical just like that
dude that [__] kept those girls in
that house you know
hey Ariel couch Ariel Kathy he killed
himself once they captured him hung
himself
this dude may not make the trial he
might hang himself he is on suicide
watch yeah okay I did I did note that
um
because like I said they said he was
crying and [__] usually these guys that
are big into control
they don't want to be controlled by a
system so they they wanna they wanna
they wanna out yeah and they want to
take the control away from the system
the only way to do that in his situation
is to
well that's why I'm glad that they
[__] snuck up on the [__] and
got him in there it's him because I well
I want to know how many other people he
[__] killed a whole bunch I mean they
might be able to clear a bunch of
unsolved murders now because of this
he's gonna be like Gary Ridgeway and and
Charles Raider Dennis Raider should be
like that
I mean yeah
around there it's gonna be yeah I mean
I've seen estimates like I said they're
just charging them with three at the
moment because that's what they have the
most evidence for I've seen estimates as
high as 17 but they think that it might
go higher than that yeah so they must
know something let's say the same thing
as I am 20 30 around there they must
know some other [__] yeah he's old
enough to where he and he's Rich enough
and has the resources where he could
rack up and because he has property
elsewhere
there's gonna be gonna be stuff out and
I would also I would also put money on
the fact that he did not stop killing
people in 2010 no
I think that he's that's 13 years he
still had a burner phone in his pocket
when they arrested him in 2023. no he's
just got a new place where he's putting
them that's what I'm saying I think that
he's just dumping them somewhere else so
I think that they're out there there's
another
burial ground someplace where he's been
putting and he's um he's only killing a
small fractions of these girls he's
mostly just spending a lot of money on
hookers
some of me kills
yeah that's where the money went
it might have been I I kind of feel like
yeah because I don't know if he had like
a bunch of other bills like I said he's
probably getting a couple of them a week
depending on what prices are like he's
probably spending at that I wonder how
often his wife is away from home because
like he's probably spending 1500 a month
unless he's like pretending to go to
work and then just like going and
meeting hookers
oh yeah
I work late I assuming [__] I gotta do
yeah I'm sure there's always like ways
like I said so that's why I always like
people are always like how's the wife
not know I'm like
easy yeah if he's got a business kind of
business in multiple homes and vehicles
and [__] like that and I mean he lives
out on in Massapequa Park which is like
out on Long Island and he works in
Manhattan so he takes like that I don't
remember how long that takes
like on the train but it's like a little
bit of a commute and like you said he
could just say oh I got this big client
I gotta stay late or whatever it's like
dude's been doing it forever I gotta go
hang out with Rick I'll be back in a bit
right
I heard he only went out and hunted when
his wife went out of the country for
business yeah that I mean that's what
they know of for now like with the ones
but I would be very surprised I would
doubt it
because the other ones weren't like
weren't like that
you know I mean Gary Ridgeway wasn't
like that he was buried
Dennis Raider wouldn't like that he was
doing it when the wife was at home yeah
you just find ways around it
yeah he was doing both that's what I
mean you could just say
you know well because she was gone he
was able to [__] play so there's
gonna be bodies right but then there's
going to be occasional ones too when
she's there and over time those are
going to add uh I bet you most of them
when she was there just that it was over
a longer period of time she you wouldn't
notice it
yeah that's what I'm saying it's like
sometimes you'll be like Oh I'm gonna go
you know play poker with the guys or
something like that and you're talking
about maybe like one of them every two
or three months Maybe
that adds up over the years
yeah because he's been he's probably
been doing this for a really long time
yeah so
we'll see how it goes like I said his
first Court date's August 1st I think
so we'll see what he has to say for
himself
on that day I'm not sure entirely what
they're gonna do
John Gore said imagine if your inner
life revolved around hookers meeting
them and killing them at times seems
exhausting it does I agree yeah
it just it really does seem like he was
just obsessed
with it well the drive the the male sex
drive really if you really look at what
if you look at what what's behind it is
that there's a it's emotion
tends to be loneliness
um
so that's one it's loneliness and
physical attraction
so chances are he has a very dry
relationship with his wife okay
he doesn't really he's not really
fulfilled by her emotionally this is not
enough excitement it's uh it's it's not
enough news things for him
so that's his Outlet
that's his dating he's he sees it as
dating
but some of them he's got to kill
that's just part of his [__]
mechanisms happening there he's got to
punish some of them
so
you see just think you know like yeah
all your whole deal is to run around
hookers you're seeing them as hookers he
doesn't really see him that way per se
he sees him as kind of like dates
and there's good girls and bad girls
race the bad girls he doesn't like the
good girls doing that
it kills him that's what I think based
on the photographs that I've seen
of the victim
because they look like good girls
and like I said he does seem to have
like a weird controlling yeah and it's a
Madonna horror complex controlling it
narcissistic he comes across like that
too he sees one he goes you're not a
[__] you're a Madonna you can't do this
I gotta kill you
you got to be punished James says punish
them for making themselves vulnerable to
men like him yeah maybe so yeah maybe
maybe so
but like you said I I think what you
said earlier was probably kind of pretty
close to the mark where you were saying
that it's almost like a weird kind of
jealousy oh yeah well that's part of it
yeah
it's a bunch of stuff it's like jealousy
and that's why he chose those particular
he's big at that type yeah he's big and
he's not good looking he's not pretty
these these girls are little and pretty
and normal looking
and it [__] enraged him
yeah I guess I'm like jealousy
I was wondering too because you know
before he got caught because we did the
[__] the first show about the Long
Island serial killer in 2018 and he had
done so many searches
for podcasts and stuff like that about
it that I wonder if you listen to ours I
don't know I was thinking that when I
was like looking through all the Google
searches I'm like did we do we didn't do
a podcast dedicated to him though yeah
we did back in 2018. he's probably seen
it that's what I was thinking because I
was like oh that [__] because he did so
many searches and was like obsessed with
like reading [__] all the time I wanted
to know what was that what was his name
he's probably like listening to us but I
don't know if he's going to be able to
listen to it now because they're not
he's uh he's in custody now and they no
bail I think some jails allow them to
have internet see yeah yeah I don't
really know yeah although I think in
this situation given the context I don't
think they would let him have a phone or
Internet or anything because they're
like no because you'll just try to find
more [__] victims get the [__] off
there you know so I kind of feel like
they'll probably keep them away from
that and rightfully so I I think they
should
um James says highly unlikely but
possible he listened to you guys I mean
maybe like I said he did do a lot of
searches so that would be pretty weird
we have thought about that before like
when we've done shows about serial
killers that haven't been caught yet and
that was just kind of like I wonder if
he listened to this [__] thing
because some of them were like kind of
obsessed with we did a show on the
[__] uh original night soccer
yeah you've got a huge amount of hits
It's probably what before he got caught
before he got caught yeah we did it
before he got caught and then he got
caught a couple weeks later and then
that show got a while later how long was
it I don't remember but it was a while
then that show got a [__] ton of hits
and I called it on every [__] count
what that dude who that dude was and
what he was like like I said you should
be a broker D'Angelo yeah I profiled his
ass I do I knew he was a copper military
he was both yeah yeah he's both
and if I can
yeah I had his number
well we've said this before serial
killers tend to fall into like a handful
of types yeah you know and they don't
you know everybody's different but they
they all have like certain
certain similar things you know what I
mean D'Angelo was an elite Commando he'd
come in through your coming through your
windows while you're at work and set the
whole [__] house up so he could get
in later unload all your guns he'd find
out where all your [__] defensive
weapons were and then let you come home
and then [__] go in there when you
were in there with your husband he's
gonna humiliate the husband rape the
wife do all kinds of [__] weird [__]
eventually was killed
yeah and then he'd sit in the house and
eat
remember he'd always eat while they were
alive and they'd be like he'd stacked
plates on like their backs and stuff
like plates if I hear him rattling then
if I hear a red I'm gonna kill your wife
right yeah
but he'd have him out there squatted
down with the [__] plates on his head
he's that [__] all [__] thought out
James says DeAngelo was a tiny dick LOL
little dick [__] yeah he was
like a microderick [__] yeah
overcompensating
big time yeah Jesus Christ don't
overcompensate I mean the J I always
make jokes about that [__] like every
time I see like a huge pickup truck or
something like that I'm just kind of
like yeah we all know what that means
but you know what I mean but yeah it's
true though it's true in his case it was
Florida is the home of this [__]
monster trucks or like something out of
damn Mad Max I got nothing against that
[__] I'd love to have a big ass truck
these things are getting so big even
dudes like me is like Dude that [__]
truck is too big you you're just you got
a little dick you're just announcing to
the world
I'm not sure if they know that that's
what everyone is thinking but that's the
first thing everybody thinks I'm driving
through the parking lot Jen's with me
this is just [__] a couple days ago
we were [__] going to books a million
and this jacket daytime huge giant
monster truck comes as bigger than
[__] important Joe's [__] car
what the [__] and Jen looks it right at
him and he's a young guy good looking
guy in his 20s and Jacobs Jay goes he's
got a little dick
I just busted up laugh he's gonna go
Cowboy little dick Cowboy
would you need that I think Jen called
it I was like that [__] was
overcomposite so just uh word to the
wise gentlemen you know what I mean
don't that truck better not be too big
every single woman is thinking that when
she sees you actually you know what you
said Jen what did I say that's not what
you said you didn't say I bet he's got a
little bit you said that's that little
dick energy oh yeah
little dick energy yeah yeah
James says big neon signs with arrows on
your truck pointing the cab Tiny Dick I
mean you might as well you might as well
because that's what everybody's thinking
that's the [__] story that's what all
the women are thinking yeah I don't know
about dudes but that's what all the
women are thinking they're like he's got
a little dick
yeah he's like yeah he's never
commentating for something
uh uh yeah Jeff yarn says based on what
you guys were saying it feels like there
might be parallels between this guy uh
you know humor men and her bowmeister
jealousy and resentment as a motive
yeah maybe so bow Meister killed himself
too didn't he yeah went off in the woods
and
killed himself
when they thought he was closing in on
him yeah James said it was four months
later like we did the show about
original dates okay then four months he
must have went back there and checked
and then Victor said I remember
messaging Jenny on Facebook when they
caught D'Angelo yeah I remember you
doing that yeah I said you know what I
was in books I feel like I spent with
the shows for a long time ago was that
eight years ago 2018 we did that show I
think it was May of 2018. I think
but um yeah I was when we were in books
a million the other day they had that um
that book about Golden State killer uh
I'll be home in the dark they had it on
sale and I was like I was gonna get it
but I was like gee I have like a huge
stack of books already that I gotta read
I'll get it next time because I gotta I
gotta work through all those ones that I
bought
Zach says also I bet when the sentence
uh when they sentenced this dude he's
gonna immediately start crying like a
baby I mean according to his defense
attorney he already cried like and he's
like I didn't do this and it's like his
his uh attorney said he was very
distraught and I was like ah
it's an act he did that [__] yeah I
definitely think he's gonna end up he's
gonna once once there's no way out of
this [__] he's gonna [__] buck up
like [__] like Dennis did
and well you know you know I had these
other projects he's gonna be like that
he's gonna he's just gonna stand there
he's gonna [__] spill his guts
dispassionately tell everybody about
everything told her I said I had sexual
problems and
I'm gonna have to kill you now and of
course she was very upset so I gave her
some water
then I strangled her
yeah that [__] I mean like you
said it's like you talk like that it's
like it sounds like a joke but it's not
that's what he that's what he talked
like yeah he was just very matter of
fact yeah I just [__] if it's so
creepy I'm not from that background man
yeah I got no problem man I'm not a
[__] piece Nick I got no problem
being in gunfights [__] shooting and
[__] killing and everything but it's
Guys these guys are everybody's willing
in this [__] this is some kind of
[__] yeah but then just doing this
[__] for sex
I just know man I just can't see it man
no you got it [__] bust a nut
and then you gotta kill somebody
afterwards because you
had to have sex
you had to have just no man that that
[__] doesn't [__] compute with me I
just the No No well it doesn't compete
with me no I'd have to kill you I'd have
to kill you if if I saw you if you were
doing some [__] like that like I said
I'd kill you and take you out of the gym
yeah and no one would ever know exactly
what happened you'd never be found
I can't let that and I can't hand you
over to the authorities
because they just can't be trusted so
I'd have to be the angel of [__]
the angel of Retribution on your ass
and uh it ain't gonna be
quick it's gonna be slow I mean then
we'll have to feed him to an hour it's
gonna be slow yeah I just I can't let
something like that I couldn't let
anything like that
just remain
this is just not in me they can't walk
around loose no I just can't let you
walk around like that no
no or like Dexter you don't talk about I
I'll go Dexter on your ass I just can't
let you [__] walk around like that
I was kind of wanting to re-watch Dexter
yeah I never did watch the newest series
this season because they made a new
season but I never did watch it maybe I
should watch the whole thing although I
have so much other stuff I kind of
watched it
James says the men are too high on the
diesel fuel to notice the Tiny Dick
Energy
I guess they're like everybody thinks
that I'm the man the driving around
thinking and meanwhile everyone's like
it's going like that I got video proof
if y'all want to see I don't have a big
truck I got a little bitty motorcycle
with a big engine
Big 12 Buell 1200. all right and uh big
dick energy you'll see
got that [__] documented yeah he had a
document got a document
murder horn that says my witness he's
seen I said in free sample
Zach says the D'Angelo update episode
was my first one with you guys really
yeah 2018. we got a lot of uh we got a
lot of subscribers on the back of that
channel I'll buy the back of that show
yeah because of all the correct
predictions and it was a good show and
it was just that time it was
pre-pandemic everybody was in a good
mood [__] economy was [__] bagging
a lot of people came on the show around
that time
and the show was kind of in transition
we just started to do video
stream
which makes the show so much easier to
do some so much more fluid
yeah I do like it a lot better yeah it
used to be a lot of YouTube shows were
just basically slideshows yeah that's
what ours was which they were fun but
there's a lot of work and it's just not
as fluid and not enough no interaction
now we have interaction with the crowd
live it's a lot better
to know who your customers are
I mean we did go off on a lot of
tangents but whatever yeah it's okay
speaking of which it's almost 10 o'clock
yeah oh [__] I have to go to bed soon
yeah because it's I got to get up early
in the morning
go to my damn job yeah so uh so yeah so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this update
on the Long Island serial killer case
I'm sure there will be lots more [__]
about this dude coming out in the future
uh and like I said sadly I'm sure
they'll find a lot more bodies damn we
got 42 on there right now really wow I
didn't realize we had them
go ahead and hit that like button for us
that'd be awesome and we of course are
uh open for super chats and we can give
super thanks you can just give us a
super thanks if you're listening to this
uh recorded yeah you can do that you're
right Jamie says love you guys love you
too hope to catch you next stream next
stream will be Friday night and that is
our Sidetrack show yeah which is always
the fun
Side Track show where we just talk about
whatever we don't have a topic we're
doing we just drink and talk about all
kinds of current events talk about all
kind of crazy anything you guys want to
talk about you guys can uh bring stuff
into the comment sections and um
and we'll discuss it yeah well we'll try
to
you know what I mean yeah but yeah so
thanks everybody for dropping by and
hanging out with us this evening uh have
a good day tomorrow and we'll see you
guys again thank you very much Victor
thank you very much thank you
appreciative thank you very much we
gotta hold on for a little second and
maybe we gotta hold on for a second in
case we got any more anybody
because there might be some people
giving super chats
all right so yeah so have a good day
tomorrow you guys and we'll see you
again Friday night for the Sidetrack
show good night